ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर
लाइव आई थिंक लाइव मैं आ चुका हूं हेलो
हाउ आर यू आई एम गुड गुड गुड हाउ आर यू आई
एम गुड तो एक बार सभी को आ जाने देते हैं
गाइस फिर स्टार्ट करते हैं चलिए थोड़ी देर
वेट कर लेते हैं सभी को एक बार जवाइन कर
लेने देते हैं ठीक है फिर इंटरेस्टिंग सा
अपना एक आज का बांटी का एक और जर्नी हम
स्टार्ट करेंगे तो चलिए लेट एवरी बडी जॉइन
गाइस प्लीज थोड़ी देर वेट कर लीजिए दो
मिनट में आ जाएंगे सभी लोग सभी लोग दो
मिनट में आ जाते हैं ज्यादा टाइम नहीं
लगाते मुझे पता
है
चलिए हां
जी हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो
हेलो हेलो एवरी बडी हेलो हेलो हेलो क्या
हाल चाल है सबके सबके बढ़िया बहुत टाइम हो
गया हां थोड़ा सा टाइम टाइम लगा इस बार इस
वाले में आज के सेशन में है ना टाइम लग
गया थोड़ा सा राइट टाइम क्यों लगा आप ही
बताओ आप आपका रीजन आप हो मैं नहीं हूं
रीजन आप ही हो आपके कारण टाइम लगा है ये
ये आपके कारण टाइम लगा है खुद ही समझ जाओ
मैं क्या बोलना चाह रहा
हूं चलो चलो चलो मैं यहां
पे इस वाले फोन पर मैंने अपना स्टार्ट कर
दिया है
चैट सर प्लीज थोड़े क्वेश्चन पूछ लो आज
ठीक है कर लेंगे क्वेश्चन पूछ
लेंगे मैं याद हूं बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल सब याद है भाई सब याद है जो
रेगुलर व्यूवर्स है वो सब याद है एंड सब
वेलकम एव बडी एवरीवन वेलकम इन टुडेज सेशन
एंड आज की सेशन है बग बाउंट क्लास नंबर 37
आप सबको पता ही है एंड आज बहुत धमाका करने
वाले हैं बहुत कुछ हम सीखने वाले हैं
जानने वाले हैं समझने वाले हैं ए टू जड हम
चीजें करने वाले हैं लिन पे जाके डेनिक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी सर्च करना है आपको एंड
हमारी इस पेज को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा हमारी
ऑफिशियल कंपनी की पेज है सारे अपडेट से
रिलेटेड जब कुछ जो भी है आपको यहीं पे
मिलेंगी ठीक है सो गाइस अ मैं बस थोड़ा
वेट कर रहा हूं बाकी सभी लोगों का जॉइन
करने का ठीक
है
ओके फर्स्ट एवर लाइव आफ्टर कंप्लीट ऑल द
प्रीवियस लेक्चर क्या बात है
कांग्रेचुलेशन आपने सारे लेक्चर कंप्लीट
कर लिए चलो इतना गैप देना जरूरी था ना गैप
देना जरूरी था कि नहीं बहुत लोग पीछे लैग
बिहाइंड कर रहे हैं वो कवर अप कर ले रहे
हैं वह हमारे साथ मैच अप कर ले रहे हैं
प्रीवियस क्लासेस कंप्लीट कर ले रहे हैं
हालांकि उसकी जरूरत नहीं है अलग-अलग
टॉपिक्स प अभी क्लासेस हो रही है तो आप
देख सकते हो प्रेजेंट क्लासेस भी कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है पीछे पिछली क्लासेस नहीं
देखी है तो बट स्टिल अगर आपने कवर कर लिया
ट्स ग्रेट ग्रेट एंड ग्रेट ठीक है बहुत
बढ़िया ओके कैन नॉट जॉइन ड्यू टू द ठीक है
कोई बात नहीं ठीक है ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
कोई कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है ओके चलिए बढ़िया तो अभी और लोगों
को आने देते हैं अभी तो 50 भी नहीं हुए जब
तक होंगे नहीं तब तक वी कैन नॉट डू
एनीथिंग अगर 50 भी नहीं हुए तो मैं देखो
मैं लेट मैं आपको पहले ही बोला ना आप लोग
जितना सपोर्ट करोगे जितना आप दिखाओगे कि
भैया हां हम रेडी हैं फ्री में सीखने के
लिए हम रेडी हैं फ्री में क्वालिटी कंटेंट
लेने के लिए मैं आपको उतना सपोर्ट करूंगा
एंड मैं उतना आपके लिए क्लासेस लेकर आऊंगा
नहीं दिखाओगे मैं कुछ नहीं कर पाऊंगा अभी
50 भी नहीं हुए 50 अगर नहीं होते हैं
क्लास कैंसिल कर देंगे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है मुझे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है सच बता रहा
हूं मैं फिर फिर एक एक हाद हफ्ता बाद 10
दिन बाद ऐसे आ जाऊंगा मैं मिलने मैं अगर
आप फॉर्मेलिटीज करोगे तो मैं भी
फॉर्मेलिटीज करूंगा समझे ठीक है तो आप
जल्दी आ जाओ सभी लोग आ
जाओ बढ़िया सर आपसे प्यार हो गया है सच
नाइस टीचर अरे क्या बोल रहे हो भाई हे सर
वन यू आर गोइंग टू लच डीसीएसपी डीसीएसपी
जुलाई में आएगी
डीसीएसपी विल कम इन जुलाई
सर
जो जो बग आप यहां शो करते हो वह बहुत इजी
होता है बट रियल वेबसाइट में इतना भी इजी
नहीं होता है इसकी वजह से लोग
एक्सपेक्टेशन लगा लेते हैं कि यह तो बहुत
इजी
है सही है क्वेश्चन यहां पर स्टेटमेंट
बढ़िया है थोड़ा सा टेढ़ा मेढ़ा है
मतलब जो क्वेश्चन होना चाहिए वो है नहीं
बग नहीं होता बक्त तो हमने सारे कवर किए
सारे बक्स को कवर कर रहे हैं वने बिलिटी
को कवर कर रहे हैं हो सकता है जो क्लास के
टाइम में आपको इजली वो जो है मिल जाते हैं
इसका प्रॉपर एक ही रीजन है कि मैं आपको
लाइव बग्स हंट करके देने वाला काम नहीं कर
रहा कि मैंने हंट किया और आपके लिए लाकर
दे दिया कि भैया ले लो यह बग मिल गई खुश
रहो बस हो गया मैं आपको मेथड जीी सिखा रहा
हूं जो आप रियल वेबसाइट्स पर भी अप्लाई
करेंगे थोड़ी अपनी खुद की एक्सप्लोर
करेंगे खुद का माइंडसेट यूज करेंगे खुद का
दिमाग लगाएंगे एंड जब आप उसको एग्जीक्यूट
करेंगे तो आप बहुत बेस्ट रिजल्ट पाएंगे तो
आपको तरीका सिखाया जा रहा है समझ में आया
वही तरीका आपको सीखना है जैसे बच्चे को हर
एक तरीका सिखाया जाता है बच्चे को
डायरेक्ट इंजीनियर डॉक्टर तो नहीं बना
दिया जाता ना बचपन में उसको पढ़ना सिखाया
जाता है पहले ए बी सी डी क ख ग घ ये सब
सिखाया जाता है जब ये सीख जाता है
धीरे-धीरे और उसकी धीरे-धीरे अपग्रेडेशन
होती है उसमें बच्चा खुद का भी थोड़ा
दिमाग लगाता है अरे भैया ये क्या करें ये
कैसे करें ये करें वो कर लेते हैं एंड देन
वो एक टाइम पे एक्सपर्ट बनता है तो अभी आप
लोग बच्चे वाले फेज में हैं एंड ये पूरी
की पूरी ट्रेनिंग जो है आपकी पूरी क्लासेस
ये उसी फेज को ध्यान में रखते हुए बच्चे
को एक इमेच्योर बच्चे को मैच्योर वाले
स्टेज में लेकर जाने का ये पूरा ट्रेनिंग
है आपके बग बाउंटीज का और इस ट्रेनिंग का
मैंने पहले ही बोला है जो ऑलरेडी जानते
हैं नॉलेज है बग बाउंटीज में ऑलरेडी दे आर
डूइंग वीपीटी वगैरह या बग बाउंटीज कर रहे
हैं तो उनके लिए ट्रेनिंग बिल्कुल भी नहीं
है यह ट्रेनिंग सिर्फ और सिर्फ बिगिनर्स
एंड इंटरमीडिएट लेवल के लोगों के लिए है
जिनको बिल्कुल जीरो से उठा के एंड
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक पहुंचाना जा सकता है
इस ट्रेनिंग के थ्रू अन पहुंचाया जाएगा
एंड आप एक बढ़िया बग हंटर बन सकते हैं
थोड़ा दिमाग लगा देंगे तो
दैट्ची आर नॉट गोइंग टू गेट हियर बताओ
क्या हाल हो चुकी है अब आप लोग समझ गए ना
मैं क्यों मैं क्यों अ नहीं क्लासेस ले
रहा फ्रीक्वेंसी
कम हो चुकी है यही रीजन है कि अब बताओ 50
भी बोलने पड़ रहे हैं 100 तो छोड़ ही दो
100 तो लीव 50 आने के लिए भी इतना बोलना
पड़ रहा है और 50 अभी मुश्किल से हो पा
रहे हैं अब खुद सोचो आपकी साइड से जब
रिजल्ट नहीं आएंगे तो हमारे साइ साड से
कैसे आप एक्सपेक्ट कर सकते हैं सिंपल सा
फंडा है मैं आपसे कोई पैसे तो नहीं ले रहा
भाई कुछ आपसे मांग नहीं रहा बस इतना बोल
रहा हूं कि क्लास में आ जाओ भाई एक अच्छे
स्ट्रेंथ में आ जाओ ताकि मुझे देख के मजा
आए मुझे उसी में मजा आ जाता है कि भैया
अच्छे स्ट्रेंथ है बस मस्त स्टार्ट करो
क्लासेस कराओ ठीक है ट्स इट इससे ज्यादा
कुछ नहीं चाहिए ओके
चलिए बिजनेस लॉजिक ही है भाई य आज की वने
बिलिटी जो हम पढ़ने वाले हैं ठीक है अभी
50 हो गए अभी तो हो गए चलो अच्छी बात चलिए
तो आज की को हम स्टार्ट करते हैं क्लास को
हम स्टार्ट करते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
आपको एक चीज और बता देता हूं आप
जॉइन है काफी सारे लोग वो एक दूसरे से
डिस्कस करते हैं बातें करते हैं एक दूसरे
से अपनी नॉलेज शेयरिंग करते हैं एक दूसरे
की प्रॉब्लम सॉल्विंग करते हैं एंड वहां
बहुत सारी नॉलेज शेयरिंग होती है तो इसको
जवाइन कर लीजिएगा यह हमारा एक
whatsapp's इट ठीक है यह काम जरूर जरूर से
जरूर कर लीजिएगा एंड आपकी जो हमारी पेज है
लिंक न की इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा डिफ्रॉक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी
आई एम थ्रिल्ड टू अनाउंस इन्होंने जो अपना
प्रोग्रेस किया है व टॉप 10 से रिलेटेड या
जो भी है वो सब इन्होंने यहां पे करके
यहां पे डि फ्रक्स को टैग भी किया है तो
इस तरह से आप करेंगे ज्यादा मजा आएगा आपको
ज्यादा बढ़िया है हमारे पास भी अपडेट आती
रहेंगी आपको
दैट्ची रीम रिसेंटली आ आइडेंटिफिकेशन
सिक्योरिटी ए नितेश सिंह फॉर गाइडेंस तो
इन्होंने हमें टैग किया है तो
दैट्ची नहीं यार कि लाइव आ जाओ और यहां पे
टैग होंग मारते रहो बात खत्म कोई पैसे
नहीं लगने कुछ नहीं लगने हैं मस्ती से
सारे काम होते रहेंगे चलिए आज जो हम टॉपिक
करने वाले हैं गाइस उसका नाम है उसका नाम
क्या है उस वनबिल का नाम क्या है नो रेट
लिमिट नो रेट लिमिट तो नो रेट लिमिट क्या
होती है अब देखो नो रेट लिमिट को लेके ना
बहुत तरह की चीजें हैं बहुत लोगों को लगता
है नो रेट लिमिट को आउट ऑफ स्कोप रखा जाता
है अ बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स के अंदर बहुत
सारे लोगों को लगता है नो नो रेट लिमिट
कोई ऐसी कुछ खास लेबिलिटी नहीं है आज के
टाइम में ऐसा कुछ एजिस्ट करता नहीं है हर
जगह रेट लिमिट लगी होती है फलाना फलाना बट
आज के टाइम में भी बहुत सारे ऐसे
प्रॉमिनेंट वेब एप्लीकेशंस हैं जहां पे
रेट लिमिट नहीं लगी होती है प्रॉपर्ली वो
रेट लिमिट नहीं इंप्लीमेंटेड होती है एंड
इसको आप लॉजिकल बिजनेस लॉजिक फ्लज में भी
डाल सकते हो लॉजिकल फ्लज में डाल सकते हो
यानी यह एक तरह का
बिजनेस लॉजिक
फ्लज बिजनेस लॉजिकल फ्लज भी आप इसको एक
तरह का बोल सकते हो अब इसलिए अब इसको
इसलिए कहा जा रहा है कि बिजनेस के बेसिकली
क्या होता है जब ऐसी वले एबिलिटीज मिलती
है तो यह बिजनेसेस के ऊपर काफी इंपैक्ट
करती है जैसे आपका कोई बिजनेस है कोई कोई
आपकी वेबसाइट है ठीक है आपका कोई ई-कॉमर्स
बिजनेस है पूरी ई-कॉमर्स बिजनेस आपकी
वेबसाइट पर डिपेंड करती है पर चले कि
वेबसाइट पर किसी ने डीडीओ डीडीओएस अटैक कर
दिया अब यह डीडीओएस अटैक जो है इस रेट
लिमिट के प्रॉपर इंप्लीमेंटेशन ना होने के
कारण भी हो सकता है तो इस वजह से यह जो नो
रेट लिमिट यह जो पर्टिकुलर वलन बिलिटी है
इसको समझना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है बहुत
ज्यादा जरूरी है ठीक
है मोहित किंग ₹ का सुपर चैट धन्यवाद भाई
मोहित बालाजी 20 का सुपर चैट क्या बात है
धन्यवाद भाई बट हेलो सर आई एम जाहिद हसन
फ्रॉम फ्रॉम बांग्लादेश वेलकम
जाहिद हां जी इंडिया वर्ल्ड कप जीत गई है
इसके लिए बहुत-बहुत बधाई है सबको एंड
कांग्रेचुलेशन टीम इंडिया एंड होल इंडिया
ये तो सही बात है चलिए तो अब पहले हम नो
रीट लिमिट को पढ़ने एंड समझने से पहले हम
समझेंगे कि एक्चुअली ये रेट लिमिट क्या
होता है क्यों जरूरी है रेट लिमिट अब चलो
इसको ना बहुत सिंपल से तरीके से समझते हैं
मान लो एक सर्वर है एक वेबसाइट है ठीक है
कांसेप्ट को समझिए पहले फिर हम प्रैक्टिकल
आएंगे डायरेक्ट लाइव वेबसाइट्स पे आएंगे
तब मजा आएगा ज्यादा क्योंकि इसमें
पर्टिकुलर क्या है ज्यादा लैब्स में हम
कुछ कर नहीं पाएंगे लाइव वेबसाइट्स पे ही
आ जाएंगे हालांकि लैब्स आप सॉल्व कीजिएगा
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है एंड लाइव वेबसाइट पे
हम देखेंगे इसको हम कैसे एग्जीक्यूट कर
पाते हैं ठीक है सर इज एचडी एचटीबी इज गुड
फॉर लर्निंग अ फॉर बिल्कुल सही है हैक द
बॉक्स बहुत अच्छा है आप उसको कर सकते हैं
सॉल्व तो अब रेट लिमिट की बात करते हैं
भैया ठीक है रेट लिमिट क्या होता है देखो
मान लो कोई एक सर्वर है ठीक है कोई एक
सर्वर है या कोई एक कंप्यूटर है चलो इसको
एक एग्जांपल के तौर प सिंपलर एग्जांपल के
तौर प समझ लेते हैं ठीक है सिंपल एग्जांपल
के तौर पे अब मान लो ये ग्लास है चलो ये
ग्लास है मेरा इसमें फिलहाल मेरे मैंगो
शेक पड़ा हुआ है ठीक है तो ये ग्लास है अब
इस ग्लास की लिमिट क्या है इतना है इतनी
लिमिट है ना इस ग्लास की पूरी इतनी पूरी
लिमिट है इस ग्लास की राइट यानी इतने से
ज्यादा इसमें कंटेंट नहीं आ सकता किसी भी
तरह का तो अब अगर मैं इतने से ज्यादा
कंटेंट इसमें ऐड करता हूं तो
ये यह क्या होगा ऊपर से नीचे आ जाएगा बाहर
आ जाएगा ना उछल के अगर इससे ज्यादा कंटेंट
आएगा तो ये उछल के बाहर आ जाएगा बेकार हो
जाएगा तो हम क्या कर सकते हैं कि ये उछल
के बाहर ना आए इसमें इतना ही कंटेंट आए जो
इससे बाहर ना आ पाए इसकी कैपेसिटी के
अकॉर्डिंग आप पाए तो हम इसमें क्या कर
सकते हैं हम इसमें एक लिमिट लगा सकते
क्या लिमिट लगा सकते हैं भैया हम यहां तक
का एक लिमिट लगा देंगे मान लो इस जगह तक
का इस पर्टिकुलर प्लेस पर एक लिमिट लगा
देंगे इस पर्टिकुलर प्लेस प यह तुमको दिख
रहा होगा इस पर्टिकुलर प्लेट प हम क्या कर
देंगे एक लिमिट लगा देंगे यहां चलो यहां
या इससे ऊपर तक लगा देंगे यानी कि सबसे
टॉप से हल्के नीचे तक का एक लिमिट लगा
देंगे ठीक है अब यह लिमिट यहां लग गई अब
कोई भी चीज जब इसमें डाली जाएगी तो यहीं
तक आके वो लिमिट हो जाएगी रह जाएगी एंड
इससे ऊपर वह नहीं जाएगी तो इस चीज को हम
बोलते हैं लिमिट लगाना किसी भी पर्टिकुलर
थिंग्स में और जब हम इसको किसी पर्टिकुलर
रेट के अकॉर्डिंग लगाते हैं फ्रीक्वेंसी
पे लगाते हैं उसको हम रेट लिमिट कहते हैं
बस यह तो मैंने जो आपको आईडिया ये जो
मैंने आपको कांसेप्ट बताया इसको आप बफर
ओवरफ्लो का कांसेप्ट समझ सकते हैं एंड वो
भी एक डॉस अटैक में हेल्प करने वाली चीज
है बट यहां पे हम नो रेट लिमिट की बात
करें तो हम बस उस लिमिट की बात कर रहे हैं
नॉट ओवरफ्लो एंड ऑल इन सब पे हम अभी नहीं
जा रहे हैं बिकॉज़ दिस इज़ नॉट अ बफर
ओवरफ्लो क्लास ठीक है तो हम उस लिमिट को
लगाना है हमें हर जगह पे जब सर्वर की बात
आती है जब कंप्यूटर्स की बात आती है उस
टाइम में हम सर्वर के ऊपर एक रेट लिमिट
लगाते हैं कि भैया एक पर्टिकुलर टाइम में
यह सर्वर इतने ही रिक्वेस्ट को 100 1000
2000 50 500 रिक्वेस्ट को ही हैंडल करेगा
उससे ज्यादा रिक्वेस्ट अगर आ रही है सर्वर
पे तो व रिक्वेस्ट को या तो डिनायर देगा
या वो सर्विस नहीं देगा उसके बाद एंड उसके
बाद आप उस सर्वर से सर्विस नहीं ले पाएंगे
या तो आपके रिक्वेस्ट को
डिनायर को ब्लॉक कर देगा या आपको लॉक कर
देगा कुछ टेंपररी टाइम के लिए एंड
एक्सेट्रा एक्सेट्रा एक्सेट्रा ये सारी
चीजें होती हैं तो इसको हम बोलते हैं रेट
लिमिट लगाना ऑन अ कंप्यूटर सर्वर और व्हाट
एवर डिवाइस जो भी आप जिस पे भी आप लगाना
चाहते तो मुझे यह बताइए कि रेट लिमिट क्या
होती है यह समझ में आया सबको फिर हम आगे
बढ़ते
हैं
बताइए अरे भाई बफर फलो नहीं कहते या बफर
फलो होता है वह कांसेप्ट है जो मैंने
बताया बट अभी हम बफर फलो पर बात नहीं कर
रेट लिमिट की रेट लिमिट प आ जाओ
अभी ओके
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सही कमलेश बिल्कुल सही
कमलेश बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सही कमलेश बिल्कुल
ठीक है यानी कि रेट
लिमिट रेट लिमिट यहां पर रेट लिमिट अ
लिमिट ट स बीन
इंप्लीमेंटेड ऑन सर्वर और कंप्यूटर
ऑन
कंप्यूटर च च
स्टेट्स हाउ मेनी
रिक्वेस्ट हाउ मेनी रिक्वेस्ट अ
सर्वर
कैन प्रोसेस इन अ इन अ गिवन टाइम फ्रेम इन
गिवन टाइम फ्रेम बस सिंपल लिमिट ट है बीन
इंप्लीमेंटेड ऑन सर्वर कंप्यूटर वि
स्टेट्स हाउ मेनी रिक्वेस्ट अ सर्वर कैन
प्र इन गिवन टाइम फ्रेम बस सिंपल सम
टाइम्स सम टाइम्स इट कैन बी 100
रिक्वेस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट पर
सेकंड और 000
सेकंड
अकॉर्डिंग अकॉर्डिंग टू द टू द
एपीआई कॉन्फिन
एपीआई
कॉन्फिडेस अकॉर्डिंग टू द एपीआई कॉन्फिन
एंड अब जब हमने एपीआई कॉन्फिन की बात कर
ली है तो हम थोड़ी बात एपीआई के ऊपर भी
करेंगे कि भैया यह सारी चीजें तो समझ में
आ रही थी हमें सर कि ये एपीआई अब क्या हो
गया अब यह कहां से एपीआई आ गया अब यह क्या
कॉन्फिन और यह क्या पर्टिकुलर थिंग एपीआई
के ऊपर में तो आप मुझे बताइए कि आप में से
किसको किसको एपीआई के बारे में प्रॉपर
नॉलेज है कि एक्चुअली एपीआई होता क्या है
मतलब उसका एपीआई क्या होती है क्या चीज
होती है बताइए क्या काम आती है किसको
किसको पता है बता दीजिए चैट में मैं देख
रहा
हूं ठीक
है तो आपको एपीआई जानना है एपीआई के बारे
में जानना है या स्किप कर दूं
जानना के बारे में गाइस प्लीज
बताइए जानना
है ठीक है अच्छा चलो मैं बताता हूं आपको
बहुत सिंपल बताता
एपीआई
एप्लीकेशन प्रोग्रामिंग
इंटरफेस इंटरफेस ये इसका फुल फॉर्म होता
है एपीआई एप्लीकेशन प्रोग्रामिंग इंटरफेस
पता है ये क्या होता है आपको दो दो सेकंड
में समझ में आ जाएगा आपको दो सेकंड में
समझ में आ जाएगा कि क्या होता है मतलब
बहुत इजी टू अंडरस्टैंड है आप एपीआई का
यूज हर जगह हर टाइम हो रहा होता है आपको
शायद नहीं पता चलेगा या नहीं पता चलता
होगा बक बैक एंड का काम है यह बेसिकली जब
तुम कोई इंफॉर्मेशन किसी वेब सर्वर से फेच
करने की कोशिश करते हो ना कोई इंफॉर्मेशन
या कोई एप्लीकेशन किसी चीज को एग्जीक्यूट
कर रही है जैसे मान लो कि तुम एक ऐसे
एप्लीकेशन एक ऐसी पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट पे हो
जैसे कि चलो मैं आपको लाइव एग्जांपल भी
दिखा देता
हूं लेट म ओपन लेट ओपन प् चलिए मान लो कि
मैं य पर
फप कॉ ओपन कर रहा हूं ठीक
है मैंने यह फप ओपन flipkart.com ओपन किया
ठीक है अब यहां पे मैं पहले तो लॉग आउट कर
लेता हूं यहां
पे यहां पे लॉग इन का ऑप्शन है मैं यहां प
लॉगइन के ऑप्शन प जाता हूं लॉगिन का ऑप्शन
प जाऊंगा तो यहां पे आ रहा है कि एंटर
मोबाइल नंबर या ईमेल आईडी उसके बाद आता है
रिक्वेस्ट ओटीपी तो मैं यहां पे एक मोबाइल
नंबर डालता
हूं मोबाइल नंबर डाल दी ये हमारा ऑफिशियल
नंबर है तोय हमने डाल दिया उसके बाद आ रहा
है रिक्वेस्ट ओटीपी ठीक है अब हम जैसे ही
रिक्वेस्ट ओटीपी पर क्लिक करेंगे ना यहां
पे एक ओटीपी जनरेट होगी एंड उस ओटीपी को
यहां आपको डालना
है ठीक है अब यह जो काम है यह रिक्वेस्ट
सर्वर तक जाना ओटीपी के लिए
सर्वर उस ओटीपी को सर्वर जनरेट करेगा समझे
उस ओटीपी को सर्वर जनरेट करेगा फिर आप
उसको डालोगे तो वो जो रिक्वेस्ट आप भेज
रहे हो ओटीपी वाली सर्वर के पास जनरेट
करने के लिए ओटीपी वो एक एपीआई कॉल कर रहे
हो एक तरह से यू आर कॉलिंग एपीआई एक तरह
एसएमएस एपीआई बोल लो या व्ट एवर एपीआई जो
भी उसका नाम है व्हाट एवर जो भी नाम है आप
एक एपीआई को कॉल करवा रहे हो एपीआई कॉलिंग
कर रहे हो पर्टिकुलर एंड वही एपीआई आपका
उस सर्वर तक पहुंचा रहा है आपकी इस
रिक्वेस्ट को ओटीपी वाली रिक्वेस्ट को
जिसको क्या आप ओटीपी जो कि जनरेट करके
देगा तो यह एपीआई का काम होता है जिसके
थ्रू आप इंफॉर्मेशन
को सर्वर तक रिक्वेस्ट के जरिए पहुंचा रहे
हो सर्वर उसको फिर प्रोसेस करेगा बस सिंपल
सा फंडा सिंपल सा मतलब एपीआई अब अगर अब
अगर उस सर्वर पे एपीआई
कॉन्फिन प्रॉपर्ली इंप्लीमेंटेड नहीं होगी
तो क्या होगा कि हम बार-बार
सेम ओटीपी यानी कि बार-बार हम सेम ओटीपी
जनरेशन रिक्वेस्ट को सर्वर को भेजेंगे एंड
सर्वर उसको बार-बार एग्जीक्यूट करके और
हमें बार-बार ओटीपी देगा एंड इसी तरीके से
हमारे ओटीपी बमबर्ग हो जाएगी या ओटीपी का
बंबा ंग शुरू हो जाएगा एंड अगर हमने यह
1000 बार कर दिया ऑटोमेशन के थ्रू जो कि
हम बॉब शूट से करेंगे अभी आगे चलके लाइव
देखेंगे तो बब शूट के थ्रू सीक्वेंसर या
इंट्रोड या इंट्रूडर का यूज करके जब हम
इसको ऑटोमेट कर देंगे एंड वही सेम फंडा
अगर 1000 बार हम कर देते हैं तो 1000 बार
ओटीपी जनरेट हो जाएगी एंड वहां पे हमारे
पास हम कह सकते हैं कि इस एप्लीकेशन में
नो रेट लिमिट वनरे बिलिटी एजिस्ट करती है
समझ में आया सब लोगों
को बताइए कोई बात नहीं ब्रेव बी गेमिंग
चलेगा एक्सएसएस की वीडियो चलो बहुत बढ़िया
थैंक यू बताइए सभी लोगों को समझ में आया
यह चीज य यह फंडा समझ में आया क्या मैंने
बताया अभी क्या हो रहा है एवरीवन गट प्लीज
लेट मी नो गाइस प्लीज बताइए समझ में आया
एपीआई कैसे क्या करती है एपीआई किस तरी से
करती है कॉलिंग किस तरीके से रेट लिमिट
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाती है रेट लिमिट जो है वह
काम कर रही है सभी लोग रिप्लाई कीजिए
रिप्लाई करने में कोताही मत कीजिए ठीक
है ठीक है ठीक है समझ गया बढ़िया तो दिस
इज कॉल्ड रेट दिस इ जो पर्टिकुलर अब सर्वर
हमारे को ना बारबार ओटीपी जनरेट करके नहीं
देगा हजार बार अब सर्वर के ऊपर कॉन्फिन
क्या होनी चाहिए कि वहां रेट लिमिट लगी
होनी चाहिए कि भैया 100 बार ही या भैया हम
50 बार ही या भैया हम 20 बार 10 बार पांच
बार ही हम पर्टिकुलर एक सेशन से या एक
आईपी से या एक पर्टिकुलर उस पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट जो उस पर्टिकुलर जगह से
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है तो हम उसको एक बार या
पांच बार या 10 बार ही प्रोसेस करेंगे एंड
उसके बाद अगर आती है उस पर्टिकुलर आईपी या
पर्टिकुलर सेशन से तो हम उसको डिनायर
देंगे तो यह होता है रेट लिमिट लगाना दिस
इज़ कॉल्ड रेट लिमिट
इंप्लीमेंटेशन बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल सही
सूरज बिल्कुल सही एपीआई का यूज करके आप वो
भी कर सकते हैं बिल्कुल स अनदर सर्वर से
भी आप डेटा एग्जीक्यूट करवा सकते हैं कोई
भी सर्वर से आप डेटा इंटरचेंज एक्सचेंज कर
सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है सेम सर्वर
डिफरेंट सर्वर डिपेंड्स ठीक है तो ये होती
है हमारी एपीआई और इसको हम बोलते हैं रेट
लिमिट लगाना जो मैंने आपको अभी बताया
सर्वर पे वो रेट लिमिट लगी है कि भैया
इतने प पॉइंट ऑफ टाइम में आप इतने ही
रिक्वेस्ट को पर प्रोसेस अदर वाइज डिनायर
देंगे
दैट्ची दिमाग में आपके आई एसएमएस
बमिंग एसएमएस
बॉमिस एस बमिंग कुछ याद आया कि एसएमएस
बमिंग नाम की कोई चीज होती है आपके ऊपर
आपके दोस्त लोग आपके चाहने वाले करते रहते
हैं एसएमएस बमिंग है ना एसएमएस बमिंग होती
रहती है आप आप बताओ आप में से कोई कि
एसएमएस बमिंग जब होती है तो कौन-कौन से
नंबर कौन-कौन से सर्विसेस के तरफ से आपको
मैसेजेस आते हैं
[संगीत]
ई-कॉमर्स ओटीपी ठीक है मतलब नाम कुछ होगा
डिलीवरी मिा
एजिस्ट कर रही है अब बात यह है कि इनके
कुछ रेट लिमिट जो होते हैं वो हायर नंबर
ऑफ फ्रीक्वेंसी के लिए होते हैं जैसे अगर
मान लो कोई एक कंपनी है मैंने मैं एक
कंपनी हूं मैंने लगाया कि 100 तक तो
भेजेंगे 100 टाइम्स हम एक्सेप्ट करेंगे तो
क्या होगा यार कोई उसको एब्यूज कर सकता है
कि भैया 100 टाइम्स किसी एक पर्टिकुलर
इंसान को ओटीपी भेजो एसएमएस बमिंग कर दो
दैट इज द कॉल्ड दैट इज
कॉल्ड नो रेट लिमिट बट क्योंकि आप उसको
वलने बिलिटी के तौर प एंड उसको बग की तरह
कंपनी को रिपोर्ट इसलिए नहीं कर सते सकते
हैं बिकॉज़ कंपनी ने 100 के बाद रेट लिमिट
लगाई
है तो आप सोचोगे भैया कितनी बार होगा तो
हम कंसीडर करेंगे कि रेट लिमिट यहां पे
नहीं है तो मैक्सिमम टाइम्स अगर आप
एग्जीक्यूट कर पाओ जैसे मान लो कोई एक
रिक्वेस्ट है 500 टाइम्स भेज पा रहे हो तो
भैया कोई भी कंपनी ऐसी इतनी बेवकूफ नहीं
है कि वो 500 बार इंटेंशनली अलाउ करेगी कि
हां भैया 500 रिक्वेस्ट एक पर्टिकुलर
पॉइंट ऑफ टाइम में आ जाए हमें कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है वो वहां पे रेट लिमिट लगनी चाहिए
एंड वहां पे रेट लिमिट नो रेट लिमिट वलने
एबिलिटी जो है वो एजिस्ट करती है अब अगर
कहीं पे 50 बार हो जाए 60 बार हो जाए और
मान लो कहीं प 50 बार हो गया 50 बार आपने
नो रेट लिमिट वाली वहां पे लगी हुई है 50
बार आप एसएमएस कर पा रहे हो किसी को एंड
51 बार नहीं हो पा रहा 51 टाइम नहीं हो
रहा है तो वहां पे रेट लिमिट लगी है भाई
वो दैट इज नॉट अ यू कैन नॉट कंसीडर दैट अ
लेबिलिटी आप रिपोर्ट नहीं कर सकते बट वो
होते जा रहा होते जा रहा होते जा रहा है
तो करो
भाई करो बिल्कुल सिंपल
आउट ऑफ स्कोप कर देते हैं क्यों कर देते
हैं यही तो रीजन है जब आप इस तरह की
विनेबिलिटी को रिपोर्ट करेंगे एंड वह अगर
आपको आउट ऑफ स्कोप कर रहे हैं इसका मतलब
आउट ऑफ स्कोप नहीं अगर वह नहीं कर रहे हैं
उसको एंटरटेन वो यही है कि दे आर हैविंग
रेट लिमिट्स बट आप ना कुछ ही बार ट्राई
करके कुछ रेट कुछ बार ओटीपी या आपके मैसेज
आ जा रहे हैं ट्स इट खत्म आप उसी में
रिपोर्ट करते अरे भाई 50 बार हो गया अब तो
इसमें नो रेट लिमिट वाली वटी डालूंगा मैं
नहीं नहीं यार देखो तो सही उसकी मैक्सिमम
चेक तो करो मैक्सिमम क्या कहां तक जा रहा
है वो यूजुअली 500 इज अ वेरी जेनुइन नंबर
अगर 500 बार या 300 300 बार भी मान लो 300
बार से भी ऊपर आप कर पा रहे हो ये ऐसी
चीजें तो ये ठीक है चलेगा 100 से ऊपर भी
कर पा रहे हो तो चलेगा जनरली 100 से ऊपर
150 से ऊपर 200 से ऊपर करो ये दैट शुड बी
कंसीडर्ड मेरे अकॉर्डिंग हां आप कोई
प्रोग्राम ना करे वो अलग बात
है ना वो कोई प्रोग्राम ना करें दैट इज अ
डिफरेंट
थिंग ठीक है समझ में आ गया चलिए नहीं ऐसा
कुछ नहीं है मैक्सिमम एंड मिनिमम दैट
डिपेंड्स टोटली डिपेंड करता है हमारे ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है प्रोग्राम के ऊपर डिपेंड
करता है सब कुछ चलिए अब यहां पे हम इसको
थोड़ा सा समझते हैं फिर आपके लाइव
वेबसाइट्स पे भी हम आ जाएंगे ठीक
है चलिए अब यहां पे हम नो रेट लिमिट वलने
बिलिटी के अंदर रेट लिमिट सेट करने के कुछ
मेथड्स होते हैं थोड़ा हम उसको समझते हैं
रेट लिमिट सेट करने के कुछ मेथड्स होते
हैं मैं आपको वो भी बता देता हूं एक सिंपल
सा ओवरव्यू दे देता हूं हालाकी ठीक है फिर
हम प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट प थोड़ा आएंगे एक
कोटा बेस लिमिट होता है कोटा बेस लिमिट्स
एक आपका होता है टोकन बकेट एक आपका होता
है लीकी बकेट एक आपका होता है स्लाइडिंग
विंडो लॉग एक आपका होता है रेट लिमिटिंग
एल्गोरिदम का यूज करके कुछ एल्गोरिथम्स
होते हैं उनका यूज करके कौन सा भैया सिंपल
काउंटर्स डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर रेट रेट लिमिटिंग
यूजर स्पेसिफिक लिमिट्स एक उसके बाद होता
है बर्स्ट अलाउंस फिर होता है एसटीटीपी
हेडर्स फिर होता है एसटीडीपी मतलब अ
हेडर्स का यूज़ करके रेट लिमिट हम लगाएंगे
इसके अंदर एपीआई गेटवेज एंड लोड बैलेंसर्स
एपीआई गेटवेज एंड लोड बैलेंसस के थ्रू रेट
लिमिट लगाना एंड यहां पे फिर रेट लिमिटिंग
लाइब्रेरीज एंड मिडिल वेयर्स के थ्रू तो
यह सारे तरीके हैं रेट लिमिट्स लगाने के
एक सर्वर के ऊपर ठीक है अब अलग-अलग रेट
लिमिट्स को क्यों समझना जरूरी है क्योंकि
जब आप एक्सप्लोइट कर रहे होंगे रेट लिमिट
को बायपास करने की कोशिश कर रहे होंगे
देखो यहां पे वनबिल क्या है ना कि आपको
रेट लिमिट फाइंड करने से ज्यादा अगर आप
सीख गए कि रेट लिमिट को हम बायपास कैसे कर
पाए क्योंकि सब जगह रेट लिमिट लगा है
मोस्टली मोस्टली रेट लिमिट्स हर
प्रॉमिनेंट एप्लीकेशंस में लगे होते हैं
आज के टाइम में ठीक है हां बट बहुत में
नहीं भी लगे होते हैं तो जिनमें नहीं लगे
हैं उसका अगर आप प्रॉपर कुछ एग्जीक्यूशन
करके प्रॉप
पीओसीओ ना सामने पर्टिकुलर कंपनी को
प्रोग्राम को तो आपको रिवर्ड करेगी लेकिन
अगर आपने ऐसे ही कुछ भी दिखा दिया कोई
इंपैक्टफुल चीज नहीं दिखा पाई उनको तो वो
उसको क्या करेंगे उसको नॉट एप्लीकेबल के
तहत या इंफॉर्मेशन में क्लोज मार के बंद
कर देंगे कोई रिवॉर्ड नहीं कोई स्वैग नहीं
कुछ नहीं मिलेगा
आपको वो और दूसरी चीज ऑलरेडी रेट लिमिट
लगी हुई है अब उसको बायपास कर देना है
मतलब कि उसको ट्राई करना है टू बायपास पास
इट तो वो काम भी आप कर सकते हैं तो पहले
तो बायपास तो अभी बाद की बात है दूर की
बात है पहले तो बेसिक और रेट लिमिट नो रेट
लिमिट व लिमिटी फाइंड करने का पहले देख
लेते हैं फिर सब चीजें भी कर लेंगे ठीक है
अब देखो कोटा बेस लिमिट में क्या होता है
भैया फिक्स्ड विंडो रोलिंग विंडो यह दो
चीजें होती है फिक्स्ड विंडो में क्या है
लिमिट्स आर सेट बेस्ड ऑन अ फिक्स्ड पीरियड
सच एज अलांग 100 रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट मान लो
यह एक लिमिट बेस्ड होती है फिक्स विंडो
100 रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट एंड एक रोलिंग
विंडो होती है सिमिलर होता है फिक्स विंडो
के बट कैलकुलेट यूसेज ओवर रोलिंग टाइम
पीरियड प्रोवाइड स्मूदर लिमिटिंग
एक्सपीरियंस य रोलिंग टाइम पीरियड में
इसको बेसिकली कैलकुलेट करता है उसके बाद
टोकन बकेट टोकन बकेट क्या होता है भैया
बकेट इ फिड विथ टोकन ठीक है एट रेगुलर रेट
एक रेगुलर रेट प ब को फिल किया जाता है
टोकन च रिक्वेस्ट कंज्यूम अ टोकन हर एक
रिक्वेस्ट एक टोकन को कंज्यूम कर लेती है
मतलब एक बकेट है उसमें बहुत सार टोकन रख
दिए एक रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है एक टोकन को खा
एक रिक्वेस्ट आ रही एक टोकन खा एंड
रिक्वेस्ट आर अलाउड एज लंग एस देर आर टोकन
अवेलेबल ये सिंपल सा फंडा है भाई यह सिंपल
सा एक सिंपल एग्जांपल है यह बहुत सिंपल
है मतलब एक एक बाल्टी रख ली एक बकेट रख ली
ठीक है अब उसमें आपको क्या करना है फ्री
में में मैंगो रख
दिए काफी लोग हैं मान लो काफी लोग है
हजारों की संख्या में लोग है अब आप सोच
रहे हो कि कितने लोगों को कब तक खिलाया
जाए वो फ्री मैंगो आपने उस बाल्टी के अंदर
में 100 मैंगो डाल दिए अब आपने बोला कि
भैया जब तक 100 मैंगो खत्म नहीं हो जाते
तब तक हम खिलाते रहेंगे और हमारा एक रेट
लिमिट हो गई रेट लिमिट हो गया जैसे जैसे
100 जैसे ही 100 मैंगो खत्म होंगे खत्म
कहानी खत्म हम आगे किसी भी रिक्वेस्ट को
प्रोसेस नहीं करेंगे फदर कोई भी मैंगो की
रिक्वेस्ट प्रोसेस नहीं होगी वहीं पर खत्म
हो जाएगी चीज ट्स इट खत्म तो यही होता है
टोकन बकेट उसके बाद हो है लीकी बकेट अ
क्यू दैट प्रोसेसेस रिक्वेस्ट एट अ
फिक्स्ड रेट इफ द क्यू इज फुल क्यू अगर
क्या होता है फुल हो जाता है न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट आर डिस्कार्डेड एक सिंपल सा
कतार है लाइन है क्य है दैट प्रोसेस
रिक्वेस्ट एट अ फिक्स रेट एक फिक्स रेट
में व रिक्वेस्ट को प्रोसेस करता है जैसे
कि 100 रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट 50 रिक्वेस्ट पर
मिनट जैसे ही वो फुल होगा क्यू वो जो लाइन
है पर्टिकुलर वो फुल हो जाएगी तो वहीं से
बंद यह होती है स्लाइडिंग विंडो लॉग लॉक्स
आर टाइम स्टैंप ऑफ ईच
रिक्वेस्ट लॉक्स द टाइम स्टैंप ऑफ ईच
रिक्वेस्ट एंड चेक इफ द नंबर ऑफ रिक्वेस्ट
इन द स्लाइडिंग विंडो एक्सीड्स द लिमिट जो
लिमिट सेट है चेक कर रहा उसको एक्सीड तो
नहीं करर उस पर्टिकुलर टाइम में हर एक हर
एक रिक्वेस्ट का टाइम स्टैंप लगा दिया कि
भैया यह रिक्वेस्ट इतने बजे यह रिक्वेस्ट
इतने बजे यह रिक्वेस्ट इतने बजे और फिर
चेक कर कर रहा है कि इफ द नंबर ऑफ
रिक्वेस्ट इ स्लाइडिंग विंडो एक्सीड द
लिमिट कितने लिमिट लगाए थे हमने उसको
एक्सीड तो नहीं कर जा रहा है खत्म
स्लाइडिंग विंडो लॉक उसके बाद आती है रेट
लिमिटिंग एल्गोरिथम्स जिसमें कि सिंपल
काउंटर डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर रेट लिमिटिंग यूजर
स्पेसिफिक लिमिट्स ये सारी चीजें आती है
सिंपल काउंटर में ट्रैक द नंबर ऑफ
रिक्वेस्ट इन अ फिक्स्ड विंडो टाइम वही जो
अभी थोड़ी देर पहले बताया वही एल्गोरिथम
है ये डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर रेट लिमिट में यूज
फॉर डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर सिस्टम ट इंश्योर
कंसिस्टेंट रेट लिमिट अक्रॉस मल्टीपल नट्स
जब एक बड़ा सा डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर सिस्टम कोई
होता है तो उसके मल्टीपल जो अलग-अलग नोट्स
पे जो रेट लिमिट लगाया जाता है उसको हम
बोलते हैं डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर रेट लिमिट इस
पर्टिकुलर एल्गोरिथम का यूज़ किया जाता
यूजर स्पेसिफिक लिमिट डिफरेंट रेट लिमिट्स
फॉर डिफरेंट यूजर्स ऑन यूजर ग्रुप बेस्ड
ऑन देयर सब्सक्रिप्शन लेवल यूसेज पैटर्न
एंड अदर क्राइटेरिया एक्टिव
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
है इस पर्टिकुलर एल्गोरिदम का यूज किया
जाता है फॉर इंप्लीमेंटिंग द रेट लिमिंग
रेट लिमिट रेट लिमिट को इंप्लीमेंट करने
के लिए उसके बाद होता है बर्स्ट अलाउंस
अलाउ शॉर्ट बर्स्ट ऑफ हाई एक्टिविटी बाय
हैविंग अ हायर टेंपररी लिमिट विच रिड्यूस
बैक टू द स्टैंडर्ड रेट ओवर टाइम सिंपल यह
होता है बस्ट अलाउंस मतलब कि एक
हाई रिक्वेस्ट को एक पर्टिकुलर फिक्स टाइम
के लिए अलाउ करना और फिर उसके बाद श एकदम
नॉर्मल सा हो जाना ये होता है बस्ट अलाउंस
एटीटीपी हेडर्स का यूज़ करके तो भैया
इंप्लीमेंटिंग रेट लिमिट यूजिंग एटीटीपी
हेडर्स लाइक एक् रेट लिमिट लिमिट ये एक
एसटीडीपी हेडर है जिसके थ्रू रेट लिमिट
इंप्लीमेंट की जाती है एक्स रेट लिमिट
रिमेनिंग एंड एक्स रेट लिमिट रिसेट टू
इफॉर्म यूजर्स अबाउट देर रेट लिमिट स्टेटस
तो यह बताता है कि भैया इसमें किस तरह का
रेट लिमिट इंप्लीमेंट हुआ है हमारे हेडर्स
के थ्रू एपीआई गेटवे एंड लोड बैलेंस है
दिस इज वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग गाइ यही हमारा
मेन बहुत सारी चीजों में काम आता है एपीआई
गेटवेज एंड लोड बैलेंस यूजिंग टूल्स लाइक
एपीआई गेटवेज और लोड बैलेंसस टू इफोर्स
रेट लिमिट एट द इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर लेवल तो
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर लेवल पे हम जब लगाते हैं
एपीआई गेटवेज पे रेट लिमिट तो इस
पर्टिकुलर एल्गोरिदम के थ्रू लगाते हैं इस
पर्टिकुलर मतलब तरीके से लगाते हैं उसके
बाद आती है रेट लिमिटिंग लाइब्रेरीज एंड
मिडिल वेयर यूज लाइब्रेरीज और मिडिल वेयर
इन एप्लीकेशन टू हैंडल रेट लिमिट ठीक है
जैसे कि एक्सप्रेस रेट लिमिट ये जो आती है
पर्टिकुलर लाइब्रेरी नड के लिए तो नट ड जए
में हम इसका यूज करते हैं रेट लिमिट को
इंप्लीमेंट करने के लिए नोट जेएस आप सबको
अगर नहीं पता तो प्लीज एक बार गल कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है जब आप जेएस वगैरह सीख रहे
होते हैं मन स्टैक वगैरह तो उसमें आपको
नोट जीएस का जो है इंपॉर्टेंस समझ में
आएगा नोट जस्ट इ वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग
लैंग्वेज जो आपको सीखना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल
से अगर आप थोड़ा इंटरेस्टेड है अगर उस
पार्ट में तो मन वगैरह में तो ठीक है चलिए
तो यह तो आपको समझ में आ चुका होगा सारी
चीजें कि किस तरीके से रेट लिमिट यहां पे
क्या हो रही है भैया यहां पे इंप्लीमेंट
हो रही है चलिए अब यहां पे आते हैं कि एक
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज जो हमारे लिए काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है रेट लिमिटिंग एल्गोरिथम
बेस्ड ऑन सेशन और आईपी एड्रेस इंफॉर्मेशन
इन द सेशन कैश टिपिकली इवॉल्व द फॉलोइंग
स्टेप्स अब ये क्या है ना कि जब आप
पर्टिकुलर अपने सिस्टम से किसी रिक्वेस्ट
को भेज रहे हैं ठीक है तो आपकी एक आईपी
एड्रेस होती है ठीक है आईपी एड्रेस
इंफॉर्मेशन होती है आपका एक सेशन होता है
एंड उस सेशन कैश के बेसिस पर रेट लिमिटिंग
जो है वह कुछ यह स्टेप्स को इंक्लूड करती
है क्या होता है किस तरीके से आप देखिए
क्या इसमें प्रोसेस होता है इनिशियल सेशन
डाटा पहला दूसरा चेक रेट लिमिट तीसरा
अपडेट सेशन डाटा चौथा इफोर्स रेट लिमिट इस
तरीके से यह रेट लिमिट जो है इंप्लीमेंट
की जाती है ठीक है बेस्ड ऑन द आईपी एड्रेस
इंफॉर्मेशन इन द सेशन कैश ठीक है कैसे
होता है जब आप पर्टिकुलर एक आई या एक सेशन
से कोई रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हैं तो उस उस समय
उस रिक्वेस्ट को कैसे रेट लिमिट केन सीनस
रेट लिमिट के सेंस में देखा जाता है वह
आपको यहां पे बताया जाएगा ठीक है चलिए तो
यहां पे सबसे पहले आते हैं इनिश इज सेशन
डाटा व्हेन अ यूजर सेशन और एन आईपी एड्रेस
मेक्स इट इट्स फर्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट
इनिशियलिज्म ि डाटा इन द सेशन कैस सिंपल
व्हेन अ यूजर सेशन और एन आईपी एड्रेस
मेक्स इट फर्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट जब पहला
रिक्वेस्ट वो करता है ना तो इनिशियल इज कर
देता है इट्स रेट लिमिटिंग डाटा इन द सेशन
कैश दूसरे स्टेप में चेक रेट लिमिट ऑन ईच
रिक्वेस्ट चेक द सेशन कैश टू सी इफ द यूजर
हैज एक्सीडेड द रेट लिमिट हर एक पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट पे ठीक है सेशन कैश को चेक किया
जाता है कि भैया यूजर कहीं रेट लिमिट को
एक्सीड तो नहीं कर रहा अपडेट सेशन डाटा
अपडेट द सेशन डाटा विद द न्यू रिक्वेस्ट
इंफॉर्मेशन अपडेट किया जाता है सेशन डाटा
को जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन उसको मिली हुई रहती
है और उसके बाद इंफोर्स रेट लिमिट इफ द
रेट लिमिट इज एक्सीडेड डिनायर रिक्वेस्ट
एंड ऑप्शनली प्रोवाइड अ रिस्पांस
इंडिकेटिंग द लिमिट हैज बीन रीज फिर आपकी
सब क्या करती है भैया कि अगर लिमिट एक्जिट
कर दी है उस पर्टिकुलर यूजर ने अकॉर्डिंग
टू द रेट लिमिट एल्गोरिदम देन सवर आपको
बोलता है कि भैया बस चुप रहो मैं आपको
डिनायर हूं मुझे नहीं आपको कोई सर्विस
देनी है बहुत ज्यादा नाटक कर रहे हैं आप
इतनी सर्विसेस क्यों ले रहे हैं आप इतनी
रिक्वेस्ट क्यों भेज रहे हैं मेरी भी एक
लिमिट है भाई आपके लिमिट है कि नहीं है तो
बस वही लिमिट है और आप बंद हो जाइए मैं
आपको कोई सर्विस नहीं दूंगा टाटा बाय बाय
सी यू तो वहां पे सर्वर आपको टाटा बाय बा
कर देता है और खत्म कहानी वहां पे आपकी
कोई रिक्वेस्ट फुलफिल नहीं की जाएगी एंड
वहां पे रेट लिमिट इफोर्स हो जाता है गाइस
तो ये रेट लिमिट को इफोर्स करने का
इंप्लीमेंट करने का डिफरेंट अप्रोच है
चाहे तो आप
हम डील कर सकते हैं बट आपको समझना एक
पर्टिकुलर चीज एक पर्टिकुलर जो एक माइंड
में घुसना चाहिए ना एक पर्टिकुलर चीज वह
मैं करा के रहूंगा एंड वही मेरा मोटिव है
तो यह मुझे बताइए कि आपको यह जो चीज है
समझ में आई अभी तक ताकि हम फिर आगे अब
प्रैक्टिकल थोड़ा अप्रोच थोड़ा आपको
एक्साइटेड जर्नी पर लेकर चलूं मैं बताइए
सभी लोग
तब तक मैं इधर
एक क्लास के शुरू करने का उपाय कर लेता
हूं बता द सभी लोग बताइए सभी लोग क्लियर
है
ना मैं एक क्लास की स्टार्ट करने की जो
प्रोसेस है उसको कर लेता हूं ताकि जब
क्लास स्टार्ट करना हो तो तुरंत क्लास
स्टार्ट कर
देंगे बढ़िया बढ़िया
पाकिस्तान की वेबसाइट उड़ा दो क्यों भाई
पाकिस्तान की वेबसाइट से क्या दिक्कत है
यार क्यों उड़ाओ
ग रहने दो यार जाने दो यार उनकी वेब दो कु
कुछ ही वेबसाइट्स बची है उनको भी उड़ा
कैसे उड़ा दोगे कैसे
चलेगा ठीक
है हां जी हां जी बिल्कुल
चलिए ये सारी चीजें समझ में आ गई होंगी
आपको आई होप सो तो अब हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
अ अपना
एक्चुअल नो रेट लिमिट की
गाथा ओके सो सबसे पहले गाइस फर्स्ट ऑफ ल
एक कोई भी वेबसाइट हम कोई भी वेबसाइट ले
लेते हैं ठीक है कोई भी एक वेबसाइट ले
लेते हैं
ओके एंड यहां पे कोई बंदा है जो मोबाइल
नंबर अपना चैट में दे सकता है फॉर यूजिंग
रेट ताकि उसके पास व अगर मैसेज वगैरह आए
या ईमेल आईडी तो उसको वह हमें बताए कि हां
भै आ रहे हैं कि नहीं आ रहे हैं कोई है
ऐसा लाइक मैं आपसे रिक्वे मतलब आपसे पूछ
के ही कर रहा हूं अगर आप डिस्क्लोज करना
चाहो तो नहीं है तो कोई बात नहीं बट आप
बता
दो नहीं तो मैं खुद के ही हम मोबाइल पे कर
लेंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं चलो खुद के ही नंबर
पे कर लेते
हैं हां खुद के ही नंबर पे कर लेंगे ठीक
है टेंशन नहीं है खुद के ही नंबर पे कर
लेंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
ओके चलिए अब यहां पे मैं क्या करता
हूं मैं यहां पे फोन को ना मैं यहां पे
फोन को कनेक्ट कर देता हूं मेरे लैपटॉप से
ताकि आपको फोन प दिखे अगर कुछ भी आए तो
फोन प दिखे तो लेट मी कनेक्ट माय फोन थ्रू
दिस
लैपटॉप जस्ट वेट
ऑफलाइन क्यों आ रहा है भाई ऑनलाइन आ
जा ऑनलाइन आ जाओ यार व्हाट इज द प्रॉब्लम
ऑनलाइन आ चुके हैं भैया
बढ़िया फोन मोबाइल डेस्कटॉप फोन ऑन पीसी
यही है क्या फोन ऑन पीसी हां जी मिरर
फोन बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल सही
बिल्कुल सही लेट्स सी
गाइस लेट्स वेट लेट्स वेट लेट्स वेट वेट
लेट्स वेट लेट
वेट मैं यहां पे फोन शो कर रहा हूं ताकि
आपको प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट में मजा आए थोड़ा
सा चलिए स्टार्ट फोन ऑन
पीसी तो यहां पर आपका जो हमारा फोन है वो
आ चुका है ए आई थिंक कि जो भी मैसेज वगर
आएंगे वो यहां पे दिखने चाहिए मेरे ख्याल
से बिल्कुल दिखने तो चाहिए शायद ठीक है तो
चलिए अ मैं अपना ही जो हमारा जो नंबर है
ऑफिशियल उसी नंबर को यूज कर लेंगे अभी
फिलहाल के लिए तो इसको फिलहाल के लिए
मिनिमाइज कर लेता हूं मैं इसको स्टार्ट कर
लेंगे ठीक है तो हम कोई सा भी एक अ
एक वेबसाइट ले लेते हैं गाइ लेट्स टेक सम
वेबसाइट एग्जांपल तो मैं यहां पे ले लेता
हूं कौन सा ले ले क्लियर ट्रिप क्लियर
ट्रिप का लेके देख लेते हैं कोई सा भी देख
लेंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं क्लियर ट्रिप देख
लेते कोई सा भी देख लो ओके य आ रहा है हम
बब शूट को ओपन करेंगे वी विल स्टार्ट बब
शूट फॉर इट बॉब शूट बॉब शूट बॉब शूट बॉब
शूट को रन कर यहां
प फायरफॉक्स में बॉब शूट की प्लगइन कहां
है भैया हां जी है ठीक है
बढ़िया यहां पर हम नेक्स्ट प नेक्स्ट प
स्टार्ट पर क्लिक
करेंगे इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देंगे फिलहाल
के लिए ठीक है तो चलिए अब हम शुरू करते
हैं एंड देखते हैं ट्राई करते हैं लेट्स
फाइंड सम विनेबिलिटी
इन पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट ठीक है याद रखिएगा
दज आर कांसेप्ट एंड यू हैव टू एक्सप्लोर अ
लॉट टू लर्न अ लॉट एंड टू बिकम मास्टर ठीक
है इन बग बाउ याद
रखिएगा यहां पर मोबाइल नंबर मांगा जा रहा
है क्लियर ट्रिप में मोबाइल नंबर जब हम
डालते हैं तो लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग मैं
यहां पर मोबाइल नंबर डालता
हूं मोबाइल नंबर डाला ने एंड यहां पे
डालते ही यहां पे ओटीपी अ बोल रहा है कि
ओटीपी आ है भाई ओटीपी आएगा देखो यहां पे
ओटीपी आ गया क्लियर ट्रिप योर वन टाइम
पासवर्ड और यहां पे जब हम मैसेज ओपन
करेंगे तो यहां पे वन टाइम यह जो आ रहा है
मैसेज आपका आ गया ठीक है तो दिस इज वन
टाइम वी गॉट हियर नाउ व्हाट वी आर गोइंग
टू डू हम ट्राई करते हैं कि इस पे रेट
लिमिट है कि नहीं ये देखने का वर जस्ट
ट्राइम ठीक है जस्ट ट्राइल नहीं है तो इस
रिक्वेस्ट को हमें एक बार कैप्चर करना है
इस ओटीपी वाली रिक्वेस्ट को दिक्कत ये है
कि ऑटोमेटिक ये हो रही है तो आ एक बार
देखते हैं पहले हम एक बार देखते हैं ट्राई
करते हैं एक्सेप्ट ये हमारा हो पा रहा है
कि नहीं तो
8274 2 एंड आई डोंट थिंक इट्स इट्स मैनुअल
बट ठीक है यह ऑटोमेटेड ऑटोमेटेड यहां पे
आपका आ रहा है ऑटोमेटेड हो रहा है तो
अच्छी बात है यह दिस इज अ गुड थिंग एक बार
फिर से आ गया फिर से करते
हैं यहां करके इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर लेते
हैं यहां पर इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर लेते हैं
ओके ओके सॉरी सॉरी इंटरसेप्ट ऑन वैसे तो
जब होगा तब यहां पे बॉब शूट को इनेबल कर
लेते हैं बॉब शूट को इनेबल करते हैं
firefox.exe
जगह पे रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है इसको हम
सिंपली क्या करते हैं राइट क्लिक करते हैं
सेंड टू सीक्वेंसर कर देते हैं ऐसे ही
करना है आपको भी सेंड टू इंट्रूडर कर देते
हैं दोनों जगह भेज देते हैं एंड यहां पे
पर्टिकुलर
इस अ चीज को इस रिक्वेस्ट को क्या कर लेते
हैं इंटरसेप्ट को बंद करके इसको बंद कर
देते हैं तो यहां पे ये हुआ एंड ये देखो
ये क्या आ रहा है यू एक्सीडेड द ओटीपी
लिमिट प्लीज ट्राई अगेन आफ्टर 10 मिनट्स
समझ में आ गया आपको यहां पे इन्होंने इस
पर्टिकुलर पॉइंट पे क्या लगा रख रखा है
बताओ मुझे व्हाट दे आर इंप्लीमेंटिंग हियर
व्हाट दे आर इंप्लीमेंटिंग
बताइए
मुझे बताइए इसका मतलब क्या हुआ सभी लोग
प्लीज रेट लिमिट लगी है पर्टिकुलर ओटीपी
की है ना
चलिए अब हम यहां पे आते
हैं दो बार हमने किया था दो बार आ गए यहां
पे कोई बात नहीं बढ़िया अब यहां आते हैं
बब शूट पे बब शूट पे आते हैं चलते हैं
सीक्वेंसर पे जिधर हमने रिक्वेस्ट भेजा था
सीक्वेंसर पे जब आप आएंगे ना जब आप कोई भी
ऐसी रिक्वेस्ट को सीक्वेंसर को भेजेंगे तो
सीक्वेंसर में आप इसको तभी यूज करेंगे जब
आप यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट को देख रहे हैं और
यहां पे टोकन लोकेशन विद इन रिस्पांस में
आपका कोई एक टोकन लोकेशन यहां पे आ रहा हो
ऑटोमेटिक
जैसे कुकी के फॉर्म में या फॉर्म फीड के
फॉर्म में मैनुअली डाल सकते हैं बट अगर
आपका ऑटोमेटेड यहां पर डिटेक्ट हो रहा है
तो इट विल बी द बेस्ट थिंग अदर वाइज आप
इंट्रूडर पे जाएंगे पोजीशंस पे जाएंगे
यहां क्लियर कर देंगे सारी पोजीशंस कोई भी
एक पोजीशंस को यहां पे हम मार्क कर देंगे
जैसे कि मैंने यहां पे लेंथ 76 है या कोई
भी एक तो 76 को हमने मार्क कर दिया लेंथ
ठीक है हम इस पे यहां पे ऐड कर देंगे
पोजीशन को ऐड करने के बाद यहां पे लोट्स प
चलेंगे पेलेट्स प जाने के बाद यहां पे हम
लोड में नंबस सेलेक्ट करेंगे एंड यहां पे
हम फ्रॉम वन टू यहां पे कर देंगे अ 1500
ये हमने कर दिया सीक्वेंस वन एक बार चलेगी
आपकी अटैक और यहां पे स्टार्ट अटैक कर
देंगे और अगर इस स्टार्ट अटैक के बाद आपके
पास मल्टीपल ओटीपी आते हैं क्लियर ट्रिप
से तो वहां रेट लिमिट अवेलेबिलिटी नो रेट
लिमिट अवेलेबिलिटी हो सकती है अगर वो
मल्टीपल टाइम्स आते रहते हैं तो हम क्या
कर देते हैं अपनी फोन को स्टार्ट कर लेते
हैं यहां पे फोन को यहां रखते हैं और यहां
पे स्टार्ट अटैक करके एंड लेट्स सी फोन को
देखते हैं कि ये हमारे पास मल्टी ओटीपी आ
रहे हैं या नहीं आ रहे हैं क्लियर टिप के
तो आप देख रहे होंगे कि हमारे पास
पर्टिकुलर कोई ऐसा रेट लिमिट का कोई ऐसा
ओटीपी नहीं आ रहा यह तीन ओटीपी जो था वही
तीन ओटीपी आपको यहां दिख रहे हैं बाकी कोई
ओटीपी यहां पे क्लियर ट्रेप के साइड से
फिलहाल तो नहीं आ रहा है राइट तो यहां पे
रेट लिमिट
को ठीक है यहां
पे कोई बात नहीं
पल्लव रेट लिमिट को इंप्लीमेंट किया गया
है एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं स्टेटस
में 401 401 401 आ रहा है यहां पे यहां पे
कोई भी स्टेटस 200 ओके नहीं आ रही है तो
इसको हम बंद कर देंगे यहां पे ये काम नहीं
कर रही है इसके कहने का मतलब यही हुआ ठीक
है इट मींस दिस इज नॉट वर्किंग क्लीयरली
एंड ये हमें पता चल चुका है तो चलिए अब हम
प्रॉक्सी की तरफ चलते हैं यहां
पे सीक्वेंसर पे चलते हैं यहां पे क्लियर
कर देते हैं सीक्वेंसर को इंट्रूडर पे
चलते हैं यहां पे एंड इंट्रोड पे पोजीशंस
पे इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं चलिए ठीक है अब
हम यहां पे एक और कोई वेबसाइट पे चलते हैं
एंड उस परे ट्राई करते हैं तो लेट्स गो टू
jio.com देखते हैं यहां पे
चलके एंड यहां चलते
हैं मोबाइल नंबर है यहां पे मोबाइल नंबर
डालते
हैं ठीक है यहां पे हमने मोबाइल नंबर डाला
जनरेट ओटीपी अब देखते हैं ये jio1 तरीके
से ये लेता है उसके उसको हम देखते हैं
पहले तो यहां पे हमने जनरेट ओटीपी किया बप
शूट में आ गए यहां पे एंड यहां पे देख
सकते हैं सेंड ओटीपी इसको हम क्या करते
हैं सेंड टू सीक्वेंसर एंड यहां पे सेंड
टू इंट्रूडर दोनों जगह कर दिया इंटरसेप्ट
को ऑफ कर दिया आई डोंट नो कि हमारे पास
ओटीपी आएगी कि नहीं
देना चाहता है कोई हमारे पास j का नंबर
नहीं है तो दे सकता है नहीं तो कोई बात
नहीं हम दूसरे उस पर चलेंगे बताओ कोई है
आप में से जो
प्राइमरी नंबर मत देना यार कोई सेकेंडरी
नंबर हो तो
देना नंबर दे दो नंबर तो मिला नहीं मुझे
कोई सा
भी ओके सेमेस्टर के एग्जाम है मैं समझ गया
था थोड़ा कुछ ना कुछ होगा तभी गायब थे तुम
चलो दे दो यार नंबर
कोई मतलब तो आया नहीं
मुझे नंबर आया नहीं
मुझे उसमें दे दो यार व ग्रुप जो है बग
हंटर वाली ग्रुप है ना उसमें नंबर दे
दो बाघर वाली ग्रुप में दे
दो ओके बर वाली ग्रुप में हमारे पास आ
नंबर पल्लव इज टाइपिंग तो यहां पर शायद
मिल जाएगा नंबर
हमें ठीक
है
ओके ठीक
है ओके पल्लव ने नंबर भेजा है पल्लव अब
तुम यहीं पे रहना और मुझे बताना ओटीपी आ
रहे हैं कि नहीं आ रहे ठीक है तो हम यहां
पे
9 35 62 9035 62 9035 2404 4
2404 ये नंबर पे हम ओटीपी जनरेट करेंगे
एंड यहां पे हम इसको इंटरसेप्ट करेंगे एंड
यहां पे हम जनरेट ओटीपी प क्लिक करेंगे
जैसे ही करेंगे यहां पे हमारे पास आ चुका
है सेंड टू हम इसको क्या भेजेंगे पहले से
सीक्वेंसर को जा चुका है क्या सीक्वेंसर
में पहले हमने भेजा था ना क्लियर कर लो
इसको इंट्रूडर को भी हमने पहले भेजा था
क्लियर हटाओ इसको प्रॉक्सी ब जाते हैं
सेंड टू सीक्वेंसर करते हैं यहां पे एंड
यहां पे फिर से सेंड टू इंट्रूडर कर देते
हैं कर दिया हमने इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते
हैं ऑफ किया हमने अब यहां पे ये बोल रहा
है ओटीपी सेंड सक्सेसफुली एंड यहां पे
ओटीपी चली गई होगी आई थिंक मतलब तुम्हारे
पास एक ओटीपी गई अभी एक आया ठीक है बढ़िया
एक आया बढ़िया है एक आया अच्छी बात
है तो ट्स
दैट्ची पे चलते हैं एंड यहां चलते हैं
सीक्वेंस पे सीक्वेंसर पे हम गना गाइस तो
वी हैव अ कुकी यू कैन सी हियर वी हैव अ
कुकी गट इट वी हैव अ कुकी तो पल्लव पल्लव
तो मुझे एक काम करो
तुम्हारे इसी फोन में है पल्लव यह नंबर
इसी फोन में है पल्लव यह
नंबर तो
्रीमन से तुम्हें स्क्रीन कॉल करके
स्क्रीन शेयरिंग करता हूं ठीक
है स्क्रीन शेयरिंग करता हूं तुम स्क्रीन
शेयरिंग करना मैं यहां पर कॉल कर रहा हूं
नॉर्मल कॉल प स्क्रीन शेयरिंग होती है कि
वीडियो कॉल प होती है आई डोंट नो बट देखते
हैं लेट्स सी ठीक है वीडियो कॉल पर होती
है शायद हां जी शायद वीडियो कॉल प स्क्रीन
शेयरिंग होती है तो मैं स्विच करता हूं
वीडियो में ओबवियसली
एंड वीडियो कॉल में स्विच कर लो पल्लव एंड
स्क्रीन शेयर स्क्रीन शेयर करो तुम अपना
हेलो हेलो पल्लव क्या बात है पल्लव जी
वीडियो कॉल पर हमारे स्क्रीन शेयर कर रहे
हैं थैंक यू पल्लव इतना करने के लिए हां
जी पल्लव तो पल्लव तुम वो वाला स्क्रीन
ओपन कर लो देखते हैं फिर आता है कि नहीं
यह चीज वाली स्क्रीन अपनी ओपन कर लो जो
मैसेज वाली है टेक्स्ट मैसेज वाली टेक्स्ट
मैसेज वाली स्क्रीन ओपन कर लो अपनी जहां
पर टेक्स्ट मैसेज आ रहे हैं तुम्हारे ताकि
यहां पर दिखा पाए ना
उनको तो तुम अपने टेक्स्ट मैसेज पर चले
जाओ ना टेक्स्ट मैसेज प अगर वहां पे
लाइक जा सकते हो
तो हां जी तो चलिए यहां पे ऊपर से
नोटिफिकेशन आएगी आई थिंक जब आएगा तो तो
यहां पे हमने सीक्वेंसर को वो कर दिया अब
स्टार्ट लाइव कैप्चर पे क्लिक करते हैं
ठीक है अब हम यहां पे स्टार्ट लाइव कैप्चर
पे क्लिक करते हैं एंड पल्लव का स्क्रीन
भी देखते हैं कि इनके पास ओटीपी जाते हैं
jio.com से या नहीं जाते हैं तो लेट्स सी
पल्लव मुझे नोटिफ टिकेशन दिखा दो एक बार
अगर आ रही है तो तुम्हारे पास पल्लव य यह
सब मत खोलो ना
पल्लव नोटिफिकेशन देखो अगर जिओ से तुम्हें
कुछ आ रहा है
तो फिलहाल के लिए अभी तो कुछ नहीं आ होगा
इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ है ना प्रॉक्सी इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ
है ना हा जी तो लाइव कैप्चर चल रही है
हमारी सीक्वेंसर
पर ओके रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है पल्लव कुछ हो
रहा है पल्लव आपके पास अभी तक आया नहीं ना
फिलहाल हमें नहीं कुछ मिला राइट अभी तक
नहीं आया
फिलहाल
ओके देखते हैं अभी तक नहीं आया ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं इसको थोड़ी देर
चलने देते
हैं मे बी मे बी इट्स इट्स नॉट गोइंग थ्रू
मे बी ऐसा हो सकता है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
बट एक बार देखने देते
हैं चलो चलो हमने इतनी बार कर लिया अभी तक
हमें कुछ खास यहां पर मिला नहीं हमें तो
यहां स्टॉप कर लेते हैं एक बार यहां पे
स्टॉप कर लेते हैं अब हम चलते हैं
इंट्रूडर पे इंट्रूडर पे चलते हैं पोजीशंस
पे चलते हैं यहां पे क्लियर कर लेते हैं
पोजीशंस पे कोई भी एक पोजीशंस को पकड़
लेते हैं जैसे कि मैंने इस पोजीशन को
पकड़ा यहां पे ऐड कर देते हैं यहां पे
लोट्स पे चलते हैं सिंपल सा यहां चलते हैं
नंबर्स पे अ नंबर्स पे यहां फ्रॉम वन
फ्रॉम वन टू एंड यहां पे 1500 कर देते हैं
एंड ये वन टाइम रहेगा एंड यहां स्टार्ट
अटैक करते हैं एंड देन पल्लव की फोन को
देखते हैं शायद इसमें कुछ आए या ना आए पता
नहीं कुछ भी हो सकता है नहीं आ रहे इसका
मतलब है इट्स नॉट वर्किंग मतलब j पे यह
काम नहीं कर रहा सिंपल सा फंड है सो
लेट्स ठीक है यहां नहीं आ रहा नोटिफिकेशन
देखना एक बार पलो आई डोंट थिंक सो ट् या
कौन सा आया एकय आ रहे आ रहे आ रहे इस पर आ
रहे
ना इस पर शायद आ रहे हैं
यह कौन सा ये तो यह तो एसएमएस बमिंग
एसएमएस बमिंग क्या रही
है हां ये एसएस बमिंग कोई कर रहा है ये
एसएमएस बमिंग मत करो यार तुम लोग एसएमएस
बमिंग मत करो को इसलिए नंबर नहीं बताते ना
कोई कि आप एसएमएस बमिंग करो ये अच्छी बात
थोड़ी ना है खुद सोचो हाउ इज इट गुड थिंग
मत करो प्लीज रिक्वेस्ट है यार जो भी कर
रहा है प्लीज मत करो ठीक है तो यहां पे
पर्टिकुलर यह चीज काम नहीं कर रही है कोई
बात नहीं इसको इसको होल्ड करते हैं कोई
बात नहीं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है पल तुम
स्क्रीन शेयर बंद कर लो स्क्रीन शेयरिंग
बंद कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है चलो मैंने बंद कर दिया यहां पे स्क्रीन
शेयरिंग कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है पल स्क्रीन
शेयरिंग हमने बंद कर दिया ठीक है चलिए तो
यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए मैं इसको यहां पे
वो कर देता हूं ये एक तरीका है जो तरीका
आपको यहां पे बताया जा रहा है इस तरीके से
आपको फाइंड आउट करना है चलिए मैं यहां पे
क्लोज करता हूं कोई और हम एक सर्विस ले
लेते हैं कोई और हम सर्विस प चलते हैं
चलिए लेट्स गो टू सम अदर वेबसाइट लेट्स गो
टू सम अर द वेबसाइट्स लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक
लाइक कहीं ना कहीं तो मिलेगा जाएगा तो
कहां जाएगा अब पर्टिकुलर ये जो पर्टिकुलर
चीज है आप रेट लिमिट जो लेबिलिटी है नो
रेट लिमिट वाली ये सिर्फ ओटीपी के लिए
नहीं है ये ईमेल ओटीपी हो गई या ईमेल जो
होती है पासवर्ड रिक्वेस्ट रिसेट लिंक जो
भेजी जाती है या साइन अप के बाद जो होती
है कमेंट सेक्शन में हर जगह जहां पे एक
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है उस जगह पे आप नो रेट
लिमिट ट्राई कर सकते हो यू कैन गो फरदर नो
रेट लिमिट ठीक है तो मशो पे बोल रहे हैं
मशो पे एक बार ट्राई मार लेते हैं सभी लोग
मशो मशो कर रहे हैं हम भी मशो कर लेते हैं
क्या दिक्कत है
चलो प्रोफाइल साइन अप क्यों भाई लॉग इन
नहीं होता क्या अच्छा यह नंबर
है चलिए हमने नंबर डाला यहां पर कंटिन्यू
करने से पहले इंटरसेप्ट कर लेते हैं एंड
यहां पर भैया हम कंटिन्यू कर लेते हैं
उसके बाद यहां पर क्या आ रहा है
फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड मीशो रिक्वेस्ट ओटीपी आ
रही है बहुत बढ़िया राइट क्लिक करके सेंड
टू सीक्वेंसर पे चले जाएंगे राइट क्लिक
करके सेंड टू इंट्रूडर प चले जाएंगे
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देंगे एंड यहां पे हम
देखेंगे कि हमें एक ओटीपी आई है मशो से
ठीक है भैया यहां पे हमें क्या आई है भैया
यहां से मशो से ओटीपी आई है चलो ये ओटीपी
आई है मशो से चलो ठीक है अब यहां पे इसको
ना हम फिलहाल के लिए क्या कर देते हैं
डिलीट कर देते हैं इन सारों को इन सारों
को डिलीट कर दिया हमने ठीक है अब हम यहां
पे क्या करेंगे हमने कैप्चर किया था
सीक्वेंसर को भेजा था एंड यहां पे हमें
कुछ ऐसे कुछ फिलहाल मिल नहीं रहा तो कोई
बात नहीं इसको हम इसको हम रिमूव कर देते
हैं मशो को रहने देते हैं यहां पे हमें
कोई ऐसे टोकन नहीं मिल रहा तो हम चलते हैं
इंट्रूडर पे एक बार पोजीशंस पे चलते हैं
यहां पे क्लियर कर लेते हैं लेट्स सी कोई
भी एक पोजीशन को मार्क कर लेते हैं कोई भी
एक पोजीशन को हमने मार्क किया ऐड कर लिया
यहां पेलोड पे चलते हैं यहां पे नंबर्स पे
चलते हैं पेलोड पे यहां पे टू 1500 कर
लेते हैं एंड यहां पे एक बार अटैक करते
हैं एंड यहां पे स्टार्ट अटैक करते हैं
स्टार्ट अटैक करने के बाद यहां देखते हैं
अगर ये काम कर रहा होगा तो हमारे पास
ओटीपी के ओटीपी आने लगेंगे एंड मो पे एक
ओटीपी तो आई है बट उसके बाद नहीं आई है
कोई बात नहीं देयर इज अ रेट लिमिट लाइक
इट्स अ यूजिंग रेट लिमिट ये यहां पे रेट
लिमिट यूज हो रही है ओबवियसली
दैट्ची आ गई पहली जो जीडी रिक्वेस्ट है
आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे जीरो वाली तो
यहां पे आ चुकी है राइट तो इस तरीके से अब
आपको ना चूज करना है कोई भी एक सर्विस
जैसे अब ये तो काफी पॉपुलर सर्विसेस हो गई
काफी पॉपुलर अ जो वेबसाइट्स हैं उन पे हो
गई अब हम कोई ऐसी रैंडम वेबसाइट पे ना
छोटी-मोटी वेबसाइट्स पे ट्राई करते हैं
ठीक है तो यहां
पे करते
हैं
ग एन
[संगीत]
यूआरएल एंड यहां पर हम कर देते हैं शप
लेट्स सी हाउ दे आर आई थ ये तो फिर यहां
के होंगे भी नहीं ना शायद
यार य के है क्या य नहीं नहीं य के तो
नहीं मिले इंडिया के मिलने
चाहिए चलिए एक और कोई कोई वेबसाइट बता दो
आप कोई वेबसाइट आप ही बताओ कोई वेबसाइट
बताओ आप जो नॉर्मल सी कोई वेबसाइट बताओ
जिस पर हम ट्राई मारे
बताइए कोई वेबसाइट बताइए जहां पर ओटीपी से
रिलेटेड काम हो रहा हो एंड मैं इधर क्लास
भी स्टार्ट कर देता हूं गाइस जस्ट वेट
जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट ओके ओके ओके लेट वेट गाइस लेट्स वेट
हा जी ये हो गया हमारा होस्ट
हां जी बताइए रेड बस माइज यो माइज यो रेड
बस माइजियो
अच्छा रेड बस रेड बस भी है क्या चलिए रेड
बस प ट्राई कर लेते हैं रेड बस प ट्राई कर
लेते हैं एक और है अभी बस अभी बस इसम भी
अभी बस अभी ए बी एच आई बस अभी बस प ट्राई
कर लेते हैं रेड बस तो काफी लोग जानते हैं
लेट्स गो टू अभी बस यहां पे शायद ओटीपी
वाला सिस्टम हो जाए तो अच्छी बात है हां
शायद ओटीपी है मेरे ख्याल से तो लेट्स
गो चलिए तो यहां पे हमने डाल दिया एंड
यहां पे हम इसको क्या कर लेते हैं
रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर कर लेते हैं लॉग इन
तो यहां पे रीलोड क्या आया भाई फॉरवर्ड कर
लेते हैं फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड अभी बस
कॉ सेंड ओटीपी चलिए अच्छी बात है राइट
क्लिक करके सेंड टू सीक्वेंसर सेंड टू
रिपीट इंट्रूडर करके इंटरसेप्ट को बंद कर
देते हैं जैसे हमने बंद किया हमारे पास
अभी बस से एक जो है ओटीपी आ चुकी है तो
चलिए यह काम कर रही है मतलब यहां पे तो
ओटीपी आ रही है बढ़िया है बट अभी हमें रेट
लिमिट वो बायपास करना है भाई रेट लिमिट को
देखना है चेक करना है कि इट्स वर्किंग और
नॉट सीक्वेंसर पे चलते हैं देखते हैं
हमारे पास कोई टोकन है कि नहीं अरे वाह
टोकन भी है यहां पे सोने पे सुहा का तो
अभी बस वाली पे हम यहां पे सीक्वेंसर
स्टार्ट लाइव कैप्चर चला देंगे एंड लेट्स
सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग सो वी हैव स्टार्टेड
द सीक्वेंसर अरे भैया अरे भैया अरे भैया
ये तो कमाल ही हो गया नाउ दिस इज नो रेट
लिमिट अवेलेबिलिटी यहां पे एक तरह का आप
बोल सकते हैं हालांकि एक पट टाइम के बाद
इन्होंने जरूर रेट लिमिट लगा दी होगी दैट
इज अंडरस्टैंडिंग दैट इज अंडरस्टैंडेबल बट
यहां पे हमारे पास 10 ओटीपी यहां पे मैं
मशो वाली हटा देता हूं फिलहाल के लिए
सिर्फ अभी बस को रख लेते हैं यहां पे
हमारे पास 10 ओटीपी आए हैं लगातार रेगुलर
बेसिस पे तो व्हाई दिस हैज केम बिकॉज यहां
पे ऐसा नहीं है कि रेट लिमिट नहीं लगी है
ऐसा हम नहीं बोल सकते कि देयर इज नो रेट
लिमिट ना रेट लिमिट लगी है इसलिए ही सिर्फ
यहां पे 10 ही आए हैं टोटल ओनली 10 आए हैं
अदर वाइज ये आते रहते आते रहते आते रहते
आते रहते समझ में आ रहा
है समझ में आया सबको अदर वाइज क्या होता
है ये आता रहता आता रहता
राइट अब इस चीज को हम क्या कर सकते हैं
गाइ यहां पे 10 ओटीपी है इसको फिलहाल के
लिए मैं डिलीट कर देता हूं एंड यहां पे
मैं क्या कर देता हूं इंट्रूडर
के प्रैंक किया है ना बढ़िया अब यहां पे
चल जाते हैं इंट्रूडर पे इंट्रूडर पे हम आ
जाते हैं एक बार टारगेट पे पोजीशंस पे
चलते हैं यहां पे अभी बस वाली पे क्लियर
कर लेते हैं यहां पे कोई भी एक पोजीशन को
मार्क कर देते हैं लेट्स मार्क दिस पोजीशन
एंड यहां पे पेलोड्स पे चलते हैं हैं
नंबर्स पे चलते हैं सॉरी नल पेलोड नहीं
यूज़ करना हम नंबर्स यूज़ करने हैं नंबर्स
करने हैं व टू अ 500 कर लेते हैं कितना
ज़्यादा नहीं करते हैं यहां पे स्टार्ट
अटैक पे क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट
इज़
हैपनिंग स्टार्ट अटैक लेट्स सी इफ दैट
वर्किंग देखा यहां पे अब नहीं आ रहा नहीं
आ रहा ना सेम
सेम इन्होंने क्या किया रेट लिमिट
इंप्लीमेंट कर रखा है बढ़िया तरीके से
दैट्ची से हम यहां यहां से एक रिक्वेस्ट
भेज रहे हैं ना पर्टिकुलर सेम रिक्वेस्ट
तो यहां पे इसको वो बैन कर रहा है बायपास
नहीं होने दे रहा मतलब बेसिकली उसको रोक
रहा है जब वो रोक रहा है वहां रेट लिमिट
प्रॉपर्ली लगी हुई है तो आप इसको अब देखो
होगा क्या कई सारे बिगिनर्स क्या करते हैं
जिनको रेट लिमिट जो जब रिपोर्ट करते हैं
तो नॉट एप्लीकेबल हो जाता है एक्सेप्ट
नहीं करते या इंफॉर्मेशन क्लोज कर देते वो
यही काम करते हैं कि 10 ओटीपी आया य
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल 10 10 का लिमिट
है यहां पर 10 ओटीपी आया या जो भी इन्होने
लिमिट लगा रखी है 10 ओटीपी के बाद तुरंत
रिपोर्ट बनाएंगे अरे भैया नो रेट लिमिट है
आपके देखो यार 10 ओटीपी आ गए आपके तो यह
वो फलाना ना अरे भाई 10 ही आए यार तभी तो
रेट लिमिट वही तो रेट लिमिट है उसके बाद
ही तो लगी है
लिमिट फिर क्यों जा रहे हो आगे वो नहीं है
व बिलिटी यार दूर
रहो ठीक है दूर रहो ट नॉट अवेलेबिलिटी
दिस वे रेट लिमिट वनबिल कैन बी
एग्जीक्यूटेड फिलहाल के लिए मैं चलता हूं
सीक्वेंसर पे यहां पे क्लियर कर देते हैं
यहां चल देते हैं प्रॉक्सी पे यहां पे एक
और वेबसाइट पे चलते हैं क्लोज कर लेते हैं
रेड बस तो खैर पॉपुलर वेबसाइट है अभी
फिलहाल के लिए तो बस
बुकिंग चलते हैं कोई और वेबसाइट अगर कुछ
हो तो मेक माय ट्रिप गो आई बस आरसीडी गो
आई भी जा सकते
हैं क्लियर ट्रिप अभी बस paytm.com ना ना
ना अडानी वन व्हाट इज दिस
गो ये क्या है भैया vi.com देख लेते हैं
रियल यात्री नहीं छोड़ो हटाओ इंटरसिटी
इसमें ठीक है टीएन सीटी की क्या है ठीक है
दिस वन कैन आल्सो बी डन देखते
हैं यहां से जिंग बस है एक हां जिंग बस
है इसपे बस इस पे जा सकते हैं ठीक है
बहुत सारी हमारे पास आ चुकी है तो फिलहाल
के लिए हम चलते हैं किस पे in.via.com इस
पे ट्राई करते हैं हालांकि आई डोंट थिंक
पे होगा ब ठीक है स्टिल वी आर गोइंग टू
लॉग इन तो यहां पे लॉगइन का कोई सिस्टम है
नहीं फोन वाला है
ना यहां फोन पे लॉगिन नहीं है लेकिन ऐसा
नहीं है फोन लॉगिन नहीं है तो कुछ नहीं हो
सकता आप ईमेल वाली भी ट्राई कर सकते हो
भाई ईमेल ओटीपी ईमेल मैसेजेस सब ट्राई कर
सकते हो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
चलो इसमें देखते
हैं ईटिकट लॉगिन ओटीपी है
क्या नहीं ओटीपी यहां पे नहीं है चलो कोई
बात नहीं
बस ठीक है कहां है य लगिन है भाई
बस कुछ है नहीं लगन का क्या बात है
आगे चलके होगा कुछ लॉगइन होन शायद सर्च कर
लेते हैं दिल्ली टू
लखनऊ एजेंट लॉगिन का तो आया यहां पर हमारे
पास फिलहाल के लिए एक जुलाई की बस है चलो
यहां पर कंटिन्यू करते हैं शायद फिर आया
लॉगिन का मे
बी पे नागा डायरेक्ट आ रहा है भैया
डायरेक्ट डायरेक्ट टू डायरेक्ट य तो कोई
बात नहीं ह इसको जि बस पर आते हैं साइन अप
पर आ जाते हैं यहां पर हा जी यहां पर
लॉगइन का रहा है
तो यहां पर हमने कर दिया एंड हम यहां पर
इस रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर कर लेते हैं लेट्स
लगन लगन करते य पर ओटीपी वाली पेज आई थिंक
आनी चाहिए जिंग बस लॉग इन एंड इ देर ओटीपी
कम कंट्रोल एफ
ओटीपी ओी रिक्वेस्ट नथिंग नथिंग नथ थई
नथिंग य क्या हुआ भाई हमने क्या किया ये
हमने क्या किया चलो जिंक बस का था ओटीपी
ओटीपी आ रहा है यहां पे आप सबको यहां पे
दिखेगा लाइक वी हैव गट द ओटीपी जिंग बस
वाली ठीक है तो ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात है
इस रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर करेंगे हम बेसिकली
तो अगेन हम अगेन हम करेंगे बैक कर लेते
हैं अगेन हम साइन अप प चलेंगे यहां पर
अगेन हम नंबर डालेंगे
अगेन हमने नंबर डाला यहां पे अगेन हमने
इसको इंटरसेप्ट किया इंटरसेप्ट किया यहां
पे ट्स इट यहां हमने फॉरवर्ड किया फड किया
फरड किया फॉरवर्ड किया जिंग बस यहां पे आ
चुकी है राइट क्लिक करेंगे सेंड टू
सीक्वेंसर करेंगे सेंड टू इंट्रूडर कर
देंगे ड्रॉप कर देंगे इस रिक्वेस्ट को
ड्रॉप कर देते हैं ऑफ कर देते हैं हमारे
पास एक रिक्वेस्ट आ चुकी है अब सीक्वेंसर
प चलेंगे यहां पे हमें कोई टोकन वैल्यू
नहीं मिली है बेसिकली बट स्टिल वी विल सी
इंट्रोड प चलते हैं पोजीशंस पे चलते हैं
यहां पे क्लियर कर लेते हैं पोजीशंस को
यहां पे कोई भी एक पोजीशन को मार्क कर
लेते हैं एंड यहां पे पोजीशंस मार्क करके
पलट को करके यहां पे नंबर्स चले जाते हैं
1 500 का हम यहां पे नंबर डाल देते हैं
सीक्वेंस वन चला देते हैं यहां पे स्टार्ट
अटैक करके एंड यहां पे देखते हैं कि कुछ
होता है कि नहीं होता है तो बेसिकली अगर
कुछ अगर वले बिटीज वगैरह एजिस्ट करती है
या कुछ रेट लिमिट नहीं लगी होगी तो हमें
यहां पे मल्टीपल ओटीपी आएंगे बट फिलहाल
क्योंकि एक ही ओटीपी आई है फिलहाल के लिए
तो हम इसको नो रेट लिमिट में तो भाई वलने
बिलिटी इसमें हम कंसीडर नहीं करेंगे एंड
वी विल से कि यास देयर इज अ रेट लिमिट
राइट देयर इज अ रेट
लिमिट आई नो बट व्हेन आई रिपोर्टेड दिस
विथ 100 ओटीपी दे नेगलेक्टेड एज इट है इट
जज रेट लिमिट बिल्कुल यूजुअली रेट लिमिट इ
आउट ऑफ स्कोप ऑन ब्राउंड एंड आई गट द
पासवर्ड रिट वाय ईमेल आई सेंड 100 एसएमएस
बट p5 ठीक है यह तब होता है देखो बहुत
सारी ऐसी रेट लिमिट की जो अवेलेबिलिटीज है
वो आउट ऑफ स्कोप होती है बहुत सारी
प्रोग्राम्स के अंदर यू आर एब्सलूट राइट
बिल्कुल सही बात है बट अगर आप नो रेट
लिमिट लिटरली नो रेट लिमिट पे लोगों को
बाउंटीज लगती है लिटरली मैं यह नहीं बोल
रहा कि आप बक क्राउड पे ही करो यार वई टू
डिपेंड ऑन अ सिंगल प्लेटफॉर्म किसने बोला
कि बकरा उट ओनली करो बहुत सारे अदर
प्लेटफॉर्म्स हैं बग बाउंटीज के जहां आप
हंट कर सकते हो इतना तो आपको पता चल चुका
होगा कितने सारे 50 प्लस बग बाउंटीज
प्लेटफॉर्म है मैनुअली आप फाइंड करो
प्रोग्राम्स को उन पे हंट करो एंड दे विल
बी दे कैन बी रिवडिंग यू तो आपको अपना ना
आपको बताना है कि मैंने एक वलने बिलिटी
यार मैंने एक वीकनेस फाइंड कि उसको सही
करो बस सिंपल नहीं तो आपके वेबसाइट पे
आपके आपके सर्वर पे आपके कंप्यूटर पे आप
के उसपे डॉस अटैक कर सकते हैं आपकी सर्विस
डिसर हो सकती है बस
दैट्ची सर्वर आपका क्लॉगड हो गया एंड वहां
पे आपकी डॉस अटैक एक तरह से परफॉर्म हो
जाती है एंड वहां पे आपकी जो वेबसाइट जो
बिजनेसेस वेबसाइट पे टोटली डिपेंडेंट है
उनकी वेबसाइट उनकी बिजनेस जो है चौपट हो
जाती है कुछ इस तरीके से
राइट भैया आई गॉट हॉल ऑफ फेम बाय वाचिंग
योर वीडियोस थैंक्स अ लॉट आकर्ष मिश्रा
क्या बात है आकर्ष बहुत-बहुत
कांग्रेचुलेशन हॉल ऑफ फेम आपको मिला
बहुत-बहुत
कांग्रेचुलेशन प्लीज आप लिंकन पे भी डालिए
और हमें टैग कीजिए ट्रॉनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी ठीक
है बिल्कुल बिल्कुल वही वही रेट लिमिट
करके डॉस मार देते हैं ऐसा होता है ऐसा
होता है चलिए तो यहां पे हम फिलहाल के लिए
इसको यहां से हटाते हैं सीक्वेंसेस से
इनको हम क्लियर क्लियर कर देते हैं
प्रॉक्सी प आ जाते हैं एंड यहां पे अब
यहां बात सिर्फ पर्टिकुलर इस चीज की नहीं
है अब पासवर्ड रिसेट वाली जो पेज है उसमें
भी कई बार नो रेट लिमिट लगी होती है कई
बार ऐसा होता है अब जैसे मान लो कहीं पे
तुम चलते हो जैसे मान लो हम कहां पे है अ
was.com पे थे ना कहां थे स् गो गो आईब पे
ही है मान लो यहां पे गो आई पे चलते हैं
यहां पे नंबर्स यहां पे आ रहा है भैया
यहां पे करते
हैं यहां पे ऑटोमेटिक यहां पे आ रहा है
यहां पे ओटीपी आ रही है ऑटोमेटिक यहां पे
ऑटोमेटिक गो आईबी को ओटीपी आ जा रही है
ठीक है बढ़िया कोई दिक्कत नहीं यहां पे
यहां पे उन्होंने लगा रखा है तो यहां पे
भी उन्होंने लगा रखा होगा 110 पर इसलिए ये
काम नहीं करेगी तो यहां जब आप रिसेट वाला
पासवर्ड रिसेट पेज प जाते हो या कोई
कंफर्मेशन मेल भेजने के लिए जाते हो पेज प
पे वहां पे भी आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो इस
चीज को मल्टीपल ईमेल्स मल्टीपल मैसेजेस
आने लग रहे हैं 1000 से ऊपर मैसेजेस आने
लग रहे हैं ईमेल्स आ रहे हैं मैं आपको एक
जेनुइन वो बता देता हूं कि 500000 अगर
ईमेल्स आप भेज पा रहे हो तो नो रेट लिमिट
वहां पे बेसिकली आप रेट लिमिट वहां पे
नहीं है एंड आप रिपोर्ट कर सकते हो अब वो
डिपेंड करता है प्रोग्राम के ऊपर जैसे अगर
मैं एक प्रोग्राम हूं अगर मैंने इस चीज को
आउट ऑफ स्कोप डाल रखा है आपने ये डाल रखा
है कि भैया इसको हम कंसीडर नहीं करेंगे तो
फिर उसको क्यों रिपोर्ट करोगे आप खुद सोचो
ना आप ऐसे प्रोग्राम्स बहुत सारे हैं जो
उसको ए भी नो रेट लिमिट को एक्सेप्ट करते
हैं या अगर पहले से रेट लिमिट लगी है उसको
बायपास करने की ट्राई करते हैं एंड देन
उसको रिपोर्ट करते हैं अगर वो बायपास हो
जाता है तो उस परे ज्यादा बाउंटीज मिलने
के ज्यादा आपके रिवॉर्ड मिलने के चांसेस
हो जाते हैं यह आपको करना
है ठीक
है प्रॉपर फॉर्मेट कुछ नहीं है प्रॉपर
सिंपल सा फॉर्मेट क्या है प्रॉपर कुछ नहीं
फॉर्मेट है यहां पर आपको बताना है
सिंपल वरे बिलिटी नेम वल बिलिटी का नाम
आपको बता देना है पहले दूसरे बार में
लेबिलिटी की डिटेल्स बता देनी है जो
लेबिलिटी की डिटेल्स है तीसरे नंबर पे आप
उस लेबिलिटी पर्टिकुलर जो लेबिलिटी आपने
फाइंड की है उसका इंपैक्ट बताइए क्या
इंपैक्ट है चौथे नंबर पे हाउ टू हाउ
टू या ऐसे करिए स्टेप्स टू
प्रोड्यूस प्रोड्यूस दैट लेबिलिटी यह
बताइए पांचवे नंबर पे मिटिगेशन है कोई
मिटिगेशन कोई है या कोई सजेशन है आप वोह
दे सकते हैं सामने वाले पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम को छठे नंबर पर आपका अगर
पीओसीओ पीसी है वह सबसे बेस्ट वन ऑफ द
बेस्ट पीसी होता है जिसमें सामने वाले को
क्लियर आइडिया लग जाता है कि आप क्या कर
रहे हैं किस तरीके से आपने फाइंड किया है
तो आप वीडियो पी वाईसी जो है या वीडियो जो
सॉरी
पीओसीओ इंप्लीमेंट आप वहां पे लगा सकते
हैं अटैच कर सकते हैं यह पूरा का एक पूरा
स्टेप्स
बस वलने बिलिटी का नाम बताना है वलने
बिलिटी की पूरी डिटेल बतानी है उसका
इंपैक्ट क्या हो सकता है वो बतानी है
क्या-क्या स्टेप्स उसको प्रोड्यूस करने
में लगेंगी वो बतानी है मिटिगेशन या सजेशन
कोई है तो वो बता दीजिए लास्ट में एक
पीओसीओ है यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
तो उसी तरीके से आपका जिंग बस है यहां पे
अभी बस है यहां पे एंड अब हम यहां पे अभी
बस में मान लो हम लॉगइन भी कर लेते हैं
मान लो लेट्स सपोज वी आर लॉग वी आर वी आर
लॉगिंग ठीक है हम यहां पे लॉगइन करते हैं
मान लो
लेट्स
वेट हमने यहां पर मैं यहां पर ओटीपी से
लॉगइन कर लेता हूं लेट सपो ठीक
है सो जस्ट वेट लेट म लॉग इन विथ द ओटीपी
ओटीपी आएगा कि नहीं आएगा अभी कि एस्ट हो
गया आई थंक एस्ट हो चुकी
ओटीपी ओके
यहां पर ओटीपी आई थिंक एस्ट हो चुकी है
चलिए अभी बस प शायद अभी नहीं आएगी बट हम
दूसरे किसी भी वेबसाइट पर चल लेंगे कोई
दिक्कत नहीं
है जस्ट एक बार देख लेते हैं
इसको या डायरेक्ट कॉल का वो कर लेंगे
लेट्स सी लेट्स सी लेट्स सी लेट्स सी चलिए
यहां पे वाया कॉल कर लेते एक
बार कॉल के थ्रू ओटीपी मंगा लेते हैं
क्योंकि एसएमएस वाली शायद इन्होने ब्लॉक
कर रखी
होगी लेट्स सी इफ दे आर
कॉलिंग ऐ कोई कॉल तो आया नहीं मुझे
कोई बात नहीं चलो जिंग पर चल लेते हैं
जिंग प या कहीं पर भी चल ले जिंग पर भी जा
सकते
क्या चलो यहां पर कर लेते
हैं ओके 5094
5094 यहां हमने ओटीपी से लॉगइन कर लिया ऑफ
मिल रहा है नहीं चाहिए ऑफ यहां पर चलते
हैं एंड
अकाउंट पर चलते हैं शायद कुछ होगा य पर
अकाउंट प प्रोफाइल आ रही है राइट य कुछ है
नहीं कुछ यार ईमेल अपडेट करनी है कुछ ऐसा
कुछ प्रोफाइल वो कुछ नहीं है यहां पर
रिसेट वगैरह का कुछ है
क्या नहीं कुछ रिसेट वगर का भी नहीं है
नॉर्मल सा है बहुत सिंपल सा इनका इंटरफेस
है तो इसको वो कर देते हैं एक काम कर लेते
हैं मशो पर चलते हैं मशो मशो प चलते हैं
यहां पर मशो को ओपन कर लेते हैं
इनमें भी कुछ ज्यादा कुछ खास तो होगा नहीं
मेरे ख्याल से अपडेट वगैरह
का चलो क्लियर ट्रिप पे चल देते
हैं क् ट्रिप पे चलते हैं अब जैसे यहां पे
ना जैसे हम चलते हैं यहां पे ठीक है अब हम
यहां पे मान लो नंबर लॉग इन कर लेते
हैं यहां पे हमने मान लो लॉगइन करया के
ट्रिप से ठीक है सो वी आर लॉगिंग इन 7326
इज द ओटीपी 7326 इज द ओटीपी एंड यहां पे
हमने लॉगइन कर लिया ईमेल एड्रेस मांग रही
है ठीक है तो हमने क्या कर दिया टेंप मेल
से अ टेंप मेल से हम एक ईमेल आईडी दे देते
हैं क्योंकि बाकी ईमेल तो हम कोई यूज़
करेंगे नहीं टेंपररी ईमेल आईडी एक यूज कर
लेंगे इतना काफी है इनके लिए सो वी आर
गोइंग टू यूज द टेंपररी ईमेल आईडी ठीक है
ओटीपी भेजेंगे शायद इस पे भी मे बी शायद
कोई बात नहीं र हमारा क्या जाता है यहां
पे हमने ओटीपी कर लिया यहां पे हम कर लेते
हैं वेरीफाई तो वेरीफाई कर लेंगे ओटीपी गई
होगी यहां पे इस पे भी हम ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं ठीक है अब यहां पे आएगी क्लियर
ट्रिप की ईमेल तो चलिए क्लियर ट्रिप की एक
ईमेल आ गई भैया ठीक है अच्छी बात है अब
यहां पे हमने जो चेंज अब हम यहां पे क्या
करेंगे यहां पे भी हम एक ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं हर एक फंक्शनैलिटी पे आप ट्राई
आउट कर सकते हो ठीक है यहां पे आया
वेरीफाई करने से पहले हम क्या करेंगे
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर देंगे एंड यहां पे
वेरीफाई पे क्लिक करेंगे बट इसको हम यहां
पे कैप्चर कर लेंगे कैप्चर करके फॉरवर्ड
कर लेते हैं फॉरवर्ड कर लेते हैं फॉरवर्ड
कर लेते हैं फ फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड इट
हैज बीन कैप्चरड र नॉट क्लियर ट्र ये रही
अ डोमेन यहां पे आ रहा है अकाउंट एपीआई
एंड दिस इज द सेम राइट क्लिक करके सेंड टू
सीक्वेंसर लेते हैं राइट क्लिक करके से
टूर कर देते हैं यहां पे फॉरवर्ड कर लेते
हैं और कोई तो है नहीं कुछ इवेंट्स इंटेक
ये तो नहीं है
ना फॉरवर्ड कर लेते
हैं यहां पे नो नो फॉरवर्ड इवेंट ड ठीक है
खत्म तो यह हमने किया क्लियर ट्रिप प यहां
पे यहां प ओटीपी आ रही है यहां प अगेन
दूसरी बार ओटीपी आई होगी शायद इस लेट्स सी
इफ ओटीपी कम दो ओटीपी आ गई अच्छी बात है य
गुड तो हमने इसको सीक्वेंसर में भेजा है
यहां पे कोई टोकन हमें तो मिल नहीं रहा
फिलहाल के लिए तो हम एक बार क्या कर लेते
हैं इंट्रोड पे चल देते हैं पोजीशंस पे चल
जाते हैं क्लियर कर लेते हैं अब हम इसको
भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं जैसे यहां पे
एक्पा जीरो आ रहा है इसको हम यहां पे ऐड
कर लेते हैं यहां पे पे लट पे चलके सिंपल
लिस्ट से हम इसको नंबर्स पे कर देते हैं
नंबर्स में हम 1 टू 500 कर देते हैं 1 टू
500 कर देते हैं एंड यहां पे हम स्टेप्स
को वन रखते हैं एंड यहां पे हम स्टार्ट
अटैक करते हैं स्टार्ट अटैक करने के बाद
वे विल ट्राई टू सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग सम
ईमेल्स कि हमें कोई ईमेल्स आ रहे हैं या
नहीं आ रहे हैं तो फिलहाल दो ईमेल जो थे
वही है और कोई ईमेल आ नहीं रही है तो
बेसिकली इट्स नॉट वर्किंग हियर मतलब
बेसिकली क्या हो रहा है कि यहां पे आपका
रेट लिमिट लगा हुआ है दैट्ची पलल ईमेल्स
नहीं तो अभी तक यहां पे ईमेल्स आ चुके
होते मल्टीपल ईमेल आईडी आ चु यहां पे
मल्टीपल ईमेल्स यहां पे फ्लोट कर चुके
होते हैं आपके पास तो आप ईमेल वाली
फंक्शनैलिटी जो है जैसे जहां पे आपको कोई
ऐसी फंक्शनैलिटी मिलती है आप वहां पे यह
काम कर सकते हैं इवन आप कमेंट सेक्शन है
उस पे कर सकते हैं कोई भी अगर कमेंट
सेक्शन कहीं पे आपको दिख रहा है यू कैन
जस्ट ट्राई इट आउट देयर ओके जैसे कि कहीं
कुछ है कि
सपोर्ट में क्या है देखते हैं सपोर्ट में
इनके क्या
है लेट्स सी व्ट्स द
सपोर्ट हां तो ट्रेवलर कांटेक्ट अस क्या
है भाई कांटेक्ट अस में बुक
टिट्स ठीक है यहां पे कुछ है नहीं यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए कोई ऐसा कुछ इनका ब्लॉग या
कुछ ऐसा पेज होता तो उस पर हम ट्राई आउट
कर लेते हैं तो सपोर्ट करियर करियर पे
चलते हैं कुछ होगा शायद सपोर्ट पे यहां पे
कुछ हो तो
अगर नथिंग एल्स लेट्स सी व्हाट इज देयर ये
तो ट्रिप से रिलेटेड है तो यहां पे कुछ है
नहीं ट्रेवल्स में क्या
है अच्छा ऐड न्यू ट्रेवलर आया अब देखो
यहां पे ऐड न्यू ट्रेवलर आ रहे है यहां पे
ऐड न्यू ट्रैवलर्स तो आपको जहां भी कोई
फंक्शन टी मिले आप वहां पे अब यहां पे ऐड
न्यू आके अब यहां पे मल्टीपल ट्रैवलर्स ऐड
करने का ऑप्शंस आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं
यहां पे यहां पे बेसिकली इनका वॉलेट
सर्विस है यहां पे प्रोफाइल है प्रोफाइल
में क्या है भैया व्हाट इज द प्रोफाइल
यहां पे व वही सेम चीज है ईमेल आईडी आप ऐड
कीजिए और चेक आउट कीजिए भैया कि क्या हो
रहा है ईमेल आईडी हो रही है कि नहीं हो
रही है काम कर रही है कि नहीं कर रही है
तो उस पर्टिकुलर
फंक्शनैलिटी पे आप करके ट्राई आउट करेंगे
कहीं पे कमेंट सेक्शन है वहां ट्राई
करेंगे कहीं पे लॉगइन साइन अप है वहां पर
ट्राई करेंगे कोई कहीं भी वहां पे आप
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं दिस इज कॉल्ड व्हाट
इज नोन एज नो रेट लिमिट यानी कि नो रेट
लिमिट लेबिलिटी सिंपल सा फंडा है एक सर्वर
एक सर्विस एक कंप्यूटर एक वेबसाइट जहां पे
रिक्वेस्ट जो जा रहे हैं यूजर्स के साइड
से उसको प्रॉपर मेजर नहीं किया जा रहा और
उस रिक्वेस्ट को एग्जीक्यूट किया जा रहा
है जितनी बार भेज रहा है यूजर उतनी बार
अगर एग्जीक्यूट किया जा रहा है बिना किसी
लि लिमिट के तो वो एक नो रेट लिमिट
लेबिलिटी के अंदर आती है अब अगर आप रेट
लिमिट लेबिलिटी फाइंड भी कर लेते हैं नो
रेट लिमिट कहीं पे किसी एप्लीकेशन पे तो
प्रोग्राम के ऊपर डिपेंड करता है कि वो
प्रोग्राम आपको रिवॉर्ड करेगी कि नहीं कई
बार कई प्रोग्राम्स इसको आउट ऑफ स्कोप
रखते हैं नॉट एप्लीकेबल कर देंगे कई
प्रोग्राम्स आपको रिवर्ड भी करेंगे तो अगर
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं यहां पे सिंपल सा
ताकि आपको ज्यादा थोड़ा सा वो लगे तो यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां नोट रे नो रेट
लिमिट ऑन फॉरगेट पासवर्ड पेज ऑफ नॉड
वीपीएन नो रेट लिमिट ठीक है ये किया गया
है नीचे की तरफ आप आते हैं नीचे की तरफ
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं यहां पे नीचे की
तरफ आते हैं नीचे की तरफ आते
हैं यहां पे नॉट सिक्योरिटी रिवॉर्ड विथ अ
बाउंट इनको बाउंटीज नन से मीडियम इसका जो
सीवियरिंग है वो मार्क किया गया है और ये
जो जो है ना ये कब किया गया 2019 में
201920 में या दिसंबर 2019 यानी 20 में
यानी कि ये रिवॉर्डेबल तो थी अब जाके बहुत
सारी प्रोग्राम्स ने क्या किया है इसमें
थोड़ा सा प्रॉ चीजें लगा दी है कि हम बहुत
जगह नहीं एक्सेप्ट करते यह फलाना निकालना
तो यहां यहां पे क्या था अ आई हैव
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
तो वही ईमेल बेसिकली क्या कर रहे हैं ये
ईमेल को फ्लड कर रहे हैं ईमेल फ्लड हो रही
है जिसकी वजह से प्रॉब्लम हो रही है
यूजर्स को यूजर्स मान लो यार कि कहीं पे
पासवर्ड रिसेट वाली चीज है और कहीं आपकी
ईमेल आईडी डाल दी गई है और वहां पे
मल्टीपल रिक्वेस्ट भेजे जा रहे हैं हजार
रिक्वेस्ट और आपके अब अब सोचो ना आपको
कैसा लगेगा आप मुझे बताओ आपको कैसा लगेगा
आप बैठे हो आराम से रिलैक्स कर रहे हो घर
में ठीक है अब आपके
किसी ने किसी एक पर्टिकुलर वलने बिलिटी
निकाली है नो रेट लिमिट की एक एप्लीकेशन
में और उन्होंने अपना आपके ईमेल आईडी वहां
डाल दी है और उस परे वो सीक्वेंसर स्टार्ट
करके अटैक स्टार्ट कर दे रहे हैं इंट्रूडर
स्टार्ट कर दे रहे हैं हाउ यू विल फील
आपको नहीं होगी क्या यार आपको मतलब बताओ
मुझे मतलब आप आपको ऑकवर्ड लगेगा कि नहीं
आपको प्रॉब्लम होगी कि नहीं उस चीज से
मुझे आप बताइए नॉर्मली किसी से अगर ऐसा
होता है किसी के साथ तो आपको प्रोब्लेमे
िक लगेगा कि नहीं बताइए मुझे
बताइए
बताइए य यू विल फील प्रॉब्लम प्रॉब्लम
होगा कि नहीं
आपके लगेगा राइट लगना भी चाहिए लगना भी
चाहिए यह जेनरिक है लगना चाहिए क्योंकि
क्योंकि व ट्स द सेम थिंग बट कई सारे
प्रोग्राम नहीं एक्सेप्ट करते ट डिफरेंट थ
देखो
य य देखो
इंटरसेप्ट दिस रिक्वेस्ट इन बॉबस एंड
फॉरवर्ड टिल यू फाउंड योर नंबर इन
रिक्वेस्ट लाइक योर ईमेल ईमेल
हियर नाउ सेंड दिस रिक्वेस्ट टू इंट्रूडर
एंड रिपीट इट 100 टाइम्स बाय फिक्सिंग एनी
आर्बिट्री पेलोड वि डज नॉट डज नो इफेक्ट
वि डज नॉट नो इफेक्ट रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है यू
विल सी गेट 200 ओके स्टेटस कोड 100 प्लस
ईमेल इन योर इनबॉक्स सिंपल सा फंड है इसने
इंट्रूडर वाली चीज की है ट्स इट खत्म
मल्टीपल कमेंट्स कर लो मल्टीपल कमेंट्स कर
लो मैं तो वही तो बता रहा हूं मल्टीपल
कमेंट्स पर कर लो मैं य पर करर ऑन साइन अप
ऑन लॉगिन कन्फर्मेशन
ऑन साइन अप कन्फर्मेशन
जितने कन्फर्मेशन पेज है कन्फर्मेशन मेल
आते हैं जो भी होते हैं ऑन कमेंट सेक्शन
कमेंट
सेक्शन ऑन ओटीपी सेक्शन
ऑन फॉर फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड
सेक्शन ऑन ईमेल या
फोन वेरिफिकेशन
सेक्शन इस तरीके से हर एक जगह प जहां पर
आपको वहां पर फंक्शन मिल रही है इस तरह का
जहां पे जिसके वजह से वहां पर क्या होगा
आपके ईमेल प या फोन प कोई ओटीपी जा रही है
या कोई मेल जा रहा है जैसे फॉरगेट पासवर्ड
किया तो क्या जाता है आपके ऊपर मेल जाता
है तो वहां पर उस रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर और
उस फॉरवर्ड पासवर्ड मेल को मल्टीपल टाइम्स
जितने टाइम्स कर सकते हैं कर दि अब मैं
आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं जब बकरा वगैरा
में आप जाएंगे वन यू विल गो टू द
प्रोग्राम्स न ब क्राउड तो यहां पे ना
बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स रेट लिमिट को
बेसिकली क्या कर देते हैं
ना खत्म करते हटा के रखते हैं अब जैसे
देखो मैं कोई सा भी एक देते अल्ट्रा
मोबाइल है मान लो इस पर चल के देखते
हैं बिल्कुल अल्ट्रा मोबाइल प आते हैं
यहां पे यहां पे आ जाते हैं आउट ऑफ स्कोप
में देखो यहां प आउट ऑफ स्कोप है यहां पे
इसमें आ रहा है क्या एनी एक्टिविटी दैट
ये चलो हटाओ यहां पे कुछ है नहीं कुछ
खास कोई भी थोड़ा बढ़िया प्रोग्राम उठा
लेते हैं कोई आई बोटा इसको देख लेते हैं
कैश आप इसको देख लेते हैं लालाला साइबर
गोस्ट वीपीएन स्क्वेयर क्रेडिट
कर्मा ओहो रपट मनी ट्री अरे कितने सारे
प्रकास है
तो यहां मुझे आपको दिखाना था आउट स्कोप
आउट ऑफ स्कोप में यहां पर देखो यहां पे ये
देखो आउट स्कोप में यहां पे क्या इन्होंने
मेंशन करा है देख लो यहां पे सिंपल सा
मेंशन है यहां पे बहुत सारे लोगों का
अलग-अलग तरह का मेंशनिंग का तरीका होता है
और कुछ नहीं है यहां पे आउ स्कोप में
टेस्टिंग ऑ थर्ड ठीक है यहां पे ठीक है
ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है रेट लिमिटिंग
ऑन एंड पॉइंट्स एंड पॉइंट्स पे रेट लिमिट
मतलब एंड पॉइंट्स पर रेट लिमिट अगर आपका
है वो तो वो कंसीडर यहां पे नहीं किया
जाएगा उसी तरीके से कैश में है नीचे आओ
मैं थोड़ा डिफरेंट कुछ दिखाना चाहता हूं
आपको देख लेते हैं कंट्रोल एफ रेट लिमिट
यहां प है क्या कहीं रेट लिमिट इसमें कहीं
कुछ मेंशन नहीं है जस्ट रिमूव इट साइबर
गोस्ट कंट्रोल एफ
रेट रेट लिमिट इज देर नॉट मेंशन कंट्रोल
कंट्रोल एफ रेट लिमिट हा जी यहां ये देखो
इन्होने क्या किया लैक ऑफ रेट लिमिटिंग अब
लैक ऑफ रेट लिमिटिंग को ही इन्होने आउट
स्कोप कर दिया मतलब कि अगर लेट लिमिट
लैकिंग भी कर रही है ना नहीं भी है मतलब
कहीं पर छूट गई है नहीं लगी हुई है उसको
भी आउट ऑ स्कोप करेंगे तो वैसे
प्रोग्राम्स प अब तुम रेट लिमिट हंड करोगे
तो तुम्हें रिवर्ड या बाउंट कुछ भी क्यों
मिलेगी नहीं मिलेगी ना भाई तो तुम ऐसे
प्रोग्राम्स प हंड करो ना जो उसको
एक्सेप्ट कर रही है याद रखना कि एक
पर्टिकुलर वनबिल या एक कोई बग एक
प्रोग्राम पर हो सकता है वह नॉट एप्लीकेबल
या नॉट एक्सेप्टेबल हो और दूसरे पे वो
एक्सेप्टेबल हो तो वैलिड होना चाहिए ट्स
व्ट मैटर्स ट्स व्ट एक्चुअली मैटर्स हो
सकता है ना यार मैं उसको एक्सेप्ट ना कर
रहा हूं दूसरा कर रहा है तो वैलिड तो है
ना तो लेबिलिटी तो हुई तो उसको कैसे नकार
दोगे यार आपकी बिजनेस की बैंड बज सकती है
क्या क्या बोल रहे हो अब किसी ने बहुत
बड़े कंप्यूटर से प्रोसेसिंग पावर
कंप्यूटर से काफी अच्छे ह्यूज रिक्वेस्ट
भेजने शुरू कर दिए और कोई लिमिट ही नहीं
है सर्वर क्रैश नहीं कर जाएगा क्या
वेबसाइट क्रैश नहीं कर जाएगी क्या डॉस
अटैक नहीं हो जाएगा क्या खुद सोचो ना
यार जस्ट खुद सोचो इमेजिन करो ना बस वही
बोलूंगा
ठीक है यहां देख लेते कंट्रोल ए
रेट लिमिट नहीं है यहां पर कुछ मेंशन
रैपिड में कंट्रोल एफ रेट
लिमिट अब देखो यहां प यहां प इन्होने
थोड़ा डिटेल में किया हुआ है एडिशनल
गाइडलाइंस में दिया हुआ है देखो डिटेल में
यह अच्छी चीज लगती है मुझे कोई डिटेल में
एक्सप्लेन करता है तो रेट लिमिट
इशू क्या भैया रेट लिमिट इशू वी इफोर्स
रेट लिमिट ऑन आवर टायर क्लाउड
द फैक्ट ट यू कैन मेक 50 रिक्वेस्ट पर
मिनट डज नॉट मीन दैट वी वंट ब्लॉक यू इफ
यू विल ट्राई मोर सो जस्ट स्किप दिस वन
इन्होने डिटेल में लि दिया भैया हमने पूरे
अपने क्लाउड एमेंट पर रेट लिमिट लगा रखा
हैरे तो मलब 50 तक लगा रखा है 50 से
ज्यादा जाओगे तो भैया हम तो तुमको सीधा
ब्लॉक मार देंगे हमारी जो तो यहां पर ऐसे
जब हो और आप इसमें कोई वाइ स निकाल लेते
हो रेट लिमिट को बायपास करने का देन यू आर
द हीरो देन दे विल रिवर्ड यू 100% दे विल
रिवर्ड
य
देखो यहां पे देखो एक्सेस में देयर इज नो
रिस्ट्रिक्शन बट सम रेट लिमिट्स में
अप्लाई अच्छी बात
है
रेट लिमिट लेट लिमिट ये देखो आउट ऑफ स्कोप
में क्या है सर्वर सिक्योरिटी मिस कॉन्फिन
में क्या है नो रेट लिमिट ऑन फॉर्म
या लॉग इन ठीक है यहां पर नो रेट लिमिट ऑन
फॉर्म रजिस्ट्रेशन नो रेट लिमिट ऑन फॉर्म
ईमेल ट्रेडिंग तो यह तीन जगह पे यह कंसीडर
नहीं करेंगे रेट लिमिट को किस पे लॉग इन
पे रजिस्ट्रेशन पे एंड ईमेल पे यानी इसके
अलावा अगर कहीं पर भी आप इसमें रेट लिमिट
फाइंड कर देते हो इस पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम
के अंदर दे विल कंसीडर एंड दे हैव टू
कंसीडर दैट बिकॉज इन्होंने यहां पर
स्पेसिफिकली मेंशन करा है कि कहां-कहां
रेट लिमिट हम नहीं इसको कंसीडर करेंगे तो
आपको प्रोग्राम्स के इन स्कोप आइटम्स से
भी पहले ना आउट ऑफ स्कोप आइटम्स और आउट ऑफ
स्कोप जो गाइडलाइंस है उसको पढ़ना चाहिए
उससे आपको आईडिया लगता है कि आप कौन-कौन
से प्रोग्राम्स मतलब कौन-कौन से वनबिल पे
हंट कर सकते हैं किस लिमिट तक किस हद तक
हं कर सकते हैं अब इन्होंने मेंशन किया है
ना तो लॉगइन रजिस्ट्रेशन ईमेल के अलावा
कहीं भी अगर तुमको रेट लिमिट मिल जाती है
कमेंट्स में मिल जाती है ओटीपी में मिल
जाती है या कहीं भी भी लगा डालो सीधा और
वो रिवॉर्ड एक्सेप्ट होगा एक्सेप्ट भी
होगा हॉल ऑफ फेम रिवर्ड जो मिलना होगा
मिलेगा गारंटी
ओटीपी डालने पर अगर रेट लिमिट नहीं है तो
कंसीडर नहीं करेंगे बिल्कुल अगर वोह
प्रोग्राम चाहे तो कंसीडर कर सकती है यार
अगर आप तुम दिखाओ तो बिल्कुल कर सकती है
अगर वो आउट ऑफ स्कोप उन्होंने पर्टिकुलर
मेंशन नहीं करा है तो करेगी कर दिया है तो
नहीं करेगी तो मेरा यहां पर ना देखो मैं
आपको पहले ही बोलता हूं बोलता आ रहा हूं
बहुत पहले से ठीक है बहुत पहले से बोलता आ
रहा
हूं बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद सर आपके कारण लाइफ
चेंज हो गई है ल फ्रॉम पुणे सर ऐसे ही
सिखाते रहिए अरे कोई बात नहीं कमलेश थैंक
यू फॉर योर गुड वर्ड्स ऐसे ही आते रहेंगे
ऐसे सीखते रहोगे मेरा मोटो जो है ना आपको
ओटीपी बायपा मतलब सॉरी मल्टीपल ओटीपी सेंड
करवाना एसएमएस बमिंग करवाना यह नहीं है
मेरा मोटो दिस इज नॉट माय मोटो टू अ इनेबल
और टू लेट यू लर्न हाउ टू एसएमएस बमिंग
एंड ऑल माय मोटो इज टू टीच यू मेथड ऑफ अ
वल्नरेबल कि ये एक वल्नरेबल ही है चाहे
कहीं एजिस्ट कर रही है कहीं नहीं कर रही
है कहीं के लिए एप्लीकेबल है कहीं के लिए
नहीं है एंड उस चीज को आप समझो सीखो हर एक
चीज सीख जाओ ना पूरी बग बाउटी में हर एक
टॉपिक सीख जाओ ना या जो छोटा है बड़ा है
नहीं है है एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है नहीं हो
रहा है इंप्लीमेंट हो रहा है नहीं हो रहा
है कंसीडरेबल है नहीं है सब सीख जाओ भाई
सीखना ही तो है सब जब सीख जाओगे तो मजा ही
आ जाएगा हर को हर तरीके से इंप्लीमेंट
करके हर तरीके से एग्जीक्यूट करना एंड देन
यू विल फील द
पावर यह होती है समझ समझ में आ रहा है गट
इट जस्ट डिस्कवर्ड योर चैनल फ्यू डेज बैक
यू आर रियली गुड आई वांट टू गेट एन
इंटर्नशिप एट योर कंपनी डि फोनिक्स
सिद्धांत मंडल थैंक यू सिद्धांत बेसिकली
इंटर्नशिप के जो है हम एक प अनाउंसमेंट
करने वाले हैं दैट वुड बी काइंड ऑफ स्किल
बेस इंटर्नशिप तो उसमें ओबवियसली दैट विल
बी नॉट पेड नो नो एनी पेड इंटर्नशिप बट
हां वी आर गोइंग टू स्टार्ट सो वी विल बी
अनाउंसिंग दैट ओके थैंक यू
सर आपने बहुत कुछ सिखाया है काश दो-तीन
साल पहले मिलते कोई बात नहीं या जब दे रहा
है दुरुस्त है एंड किसी भी सीखने की चीज
की कोई भी ऐसी लिमिट टाइम नहीं होती है
यानी कि सीखने में सीखने में देयर शुड बी
नो रेट लिमिट कोई भी रेट लिमिट नहीं होनी
चाहिए सीखने में जब टाइम मिला जब जहां समय
मिला जब जैसे टाइम आया सीखना शुरू कर देना
चाहिए एंड जब आप सीखना शुरू कर चुके हैं
वही सही टाइम है दैट इज द परफेक्ट टाइम
बिल्कुल सही जब जागो तभी
सवेरा भैया इसका वीडियो रिकॉर्ड रिकॉर्ड
वीडियो डालेंगे अरे भैया जो भी लाइव
क्लासेस होती है उसकी वीडियो ऑटोमेटिक
youtube2 पास वाली भी टेक्निक सीखेंगे अब
एक ही क्लास में सब तो नहीं पॉसिबल है
क्योंकि
टाइम हो जाता है हमारा बट या वी विल वी
विल लर्न दैट वी विल लर्न बायपास टेक्निक
आपको सीखनी है क्या आप लोगों को बता दीजिए
मुझे रेट लिमिट को बायपास करने के
टेक्निक्स को सीखने है आप लोगों को यू वाट
टू यू वांट टू लर्न गाइस प्लीज बताइए यह
तो था रेट लिमिट कैसे फाइंड करना है बहुत
सारी एक्चुअल थिंग इज हाउ टू बायपास रेट
लिमिट क्योंकि अगर आपने रेट लिमिट बायपास
कर ली तो आप मालामाल हो जाएंगे मतलब कंपनी
110 पर लिख के रखो पे करेगी 110 पर आउट ऑफ
स्कोप में है कुछ भी उसे कोई नहीं करता इफ
यू जस्ट बायपास अ रेट लिमिट यू विल गेट
रिवर्ड तो इसको हम नेक्स्ट क्लास में के
नेक्स्ट क्लास में डिटेल में थोड़ा
पढ़ेंगे क्योंकि बायपास करने के पीछे
थोड़ा कुछ मेथड कुछ मेथड कुछ चीजें हैं जो
आपको समझनी पड़ेंगी सीखनी पड़ेंगी कुछ
कंसेप्ट को समझना पड़ेगा एंड देन हम
बायपास की ट्राई कर सकते हैं जो जहां-जहां
रेट लिमिट लगे हैं ट्राई करो बायपास करने
का अब जैसे अभी देखा अभी बस पे या क्लियर
ट्रिप पे सब पे लगे हैं लगभग रेट लिमिट हम
उस पे ट्राई करेंगे बायपास करने का मिल
गया क्या दिक्कत
है हां जी नेक्स्ट क्लास जल्दी हो जाएगी
यार आप लोग सपोर्ट दिखाते रहो यार हम तो
क्लास से लेते आएंगे बस इतना मुझे सपोर्ट
चाहिए यार सीधी सी बात है तभी इनकरेजमेंट
मिलती है अगर सपोर्ट नहीं मिलेगा तो
इनकरेजमेंट मुझे नहीं मिलती मैं क्लियर कट
बात करता हूं मैं घुमा फिरा के और प पीछे
वाली बातें नहीं करता भाई सीधी सी
बात ठीक
[संगीत]
है करेंटली आई एम डूइंग अ ट्रेनिंग एंड
इंटर्नशिप ठीक है आफ्टर सम मंथ्स आई नीड
टू फाइंड जॉब सो एनी टिप्स टू डू जॉब्स
सिंपल स्किल्स गेन करते जाइए करते जाइए
करते जाइए जितना स्किल्स गेन कर लेंगे यू
विल गेट अ जॉब ठीक है बस बात खत्म क्लासेस
नहीं रुकनी चाहिए क्या बात है ं व्हाट इज
रेट लिमिट स्टिल बता दिया है ऑलरेडी
देखिएगा वीडियो दोबारा से ठीक है तो चलिए
गाइज आज के सेशन को यहीं पे एंड कर देते
हैं फिलहाल के लिए आप लोग ट्राई कीजिएगा
बब शूट से आपको पता ही दिया है मैंने कि
बब शूट में किस तरीके से आपको इंट्रूडर
एंड सीक्वेंसर में जाके आपको ट्राई आउट
करना है इंटरसेप्ट करना है रिक्वेस्ट को
जो भी रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है ओटीपी की या जो
भी मैसेजेस की कमेंट्स कि व्हाट एवर
इंटरसेप्ट कीजिएगा अलग-अलग रिवर्ड पे
ट्राई कीजिएगा बक क्राउड से आप ऐसी
प्रोग्राम्स ना फाइंड करने का ब क्राउड
वाले प्रोग्राम्स पे ना हंट करें मैनुअली
प्रोग्राम्स
ठीक है तो बस सो आज के सेशन के लिए अगले
सेशन में हम इसके बायपास टेक्निक को
देखेंगे बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग शायद आपके लिए
होने वाला है रेट लिमिट को बायपास करने के
अलग-अलग तरीके क्या होते हैं क्या हो सकते
हैं किन-किन तरीकों से किया जा सकता है वो
सारी चीजों पे हम फोकस करने वाले हैं तो
नेक्स्ट क्लास में जरूर आ जाइएगा नहीं
आइएगा तो भैया मैं कुछ नहीं कर सकता ठीक
है भैया तो बस इतना ही आज के लिए आप सबका
बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद आप सब आते हैं अच्छा
लगता है आप सब आते रहिए और भी ज्यादा
अच्छा लगेगा ठीक है दैट्ची बोलूंगा मैं
इससे ज्यादा कुछ नहीं बोलूंगा आप सबसे
रिक्वेस्ट यही है कि बस हमारे डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी पेज को